all right and we are both live the last
word with Eve on ttis episode number 50
what is up with that I know actually got
the 50/50 shut up like a mondo who
brought it to my attention he is like so
that means you guys been doing it for a
year only three months we probably had
like a couple like you know holidays and
things but yeah I'm pretty sure I got to
look back and see when one was and I
don't even know if I know but it's been
pretty much right on a year so it's been
a crazy year that's crazy yeah good
stuff going on in these Luther shooter
genre so much to talk about
yeah it's been interesting week for me I
mean um I've been so busy with other
stuff that I bought is knows about that
job that it's closed at this time but um
yeah master I've got a chance to do much
much gaming as much as I wanted to but I
might actually give it to you like what
you've been able to tackle this week
gaming wise for me has been a little bit
of iron banner is actually playing a
little bit of my hunter trying to get
her nice somewhat leveled up towards the
650 range I think he's like 645 so close
close I mean and there's a point where
I'm like it's fine from not quite there
but just trying to play through a little
bit I know I'm gonna be spending some
time and shattered throne again this
week just trying to do a couple of the
classes because I was a big request I
get so trying to see about potentially
another solo I don't know if I'll go
full-on flawless I mean if it happens
what happens I don't think I'll break my
head over it but potentially a couple
solo runs there but been playing and
he's going to anthem in down time in
Julian that week we've got some stuff to
talk about there's changes were made
events have already happened which is
kind of an crazy and then just
all-in-all yeah yes been to get my head
wrapped around these two a little bit
and then we know we've got even more
coming oh yeah there's never enough time
in the day absolutely but yes a bit I
mean a few few times I got a chance to
touch a controller or a keyboard
um I finished that I I snuck in on
crimson days right before the transition
the iron banner and I got a lot of
crimson beanies and cuz I wanted I got
the bull shout out to a stone don't you
bro
he had helped me get the UH to help me
get the bowl and we worked that out and
then a couple days later I jumped on
sole and I really just actually I did it
for the Shaq's bonus basket gift basket
you know yeah we gives you extra stuff
if you have those confectionery arts and
I was very disappointing on second yo
job what's going on go for it
I got a stream err no worries no worries
man that's what happens when you laugh
yeah I can blame what's going on man
always catching one live for the first
time that's what sub salute salute you
know my stream literally we asked you
Darryl see you going on yeah no worries
man out see what it is you got that new
cheetah icon on you thing
oh yeah so it's messing up the algorithm
which you know you're good she'll figure
it out but I'll ramble while you're
doing that
Oh Mosley hold on I'm trying to get back
so I got something to record to you no
worries no worries
mm-hmm okay I should be back yeah y'all
you're back in the building baby back
all right
sorry guys so good man so yeah like for
me it's just been on yes I did that the
crimson gaze and I was trying to get
like I said the Vagabond the GData
digits to the ground Africa can't fire
we have returned for our telepathic
looter shooter talk but um yeah so I was
doing that now just trying to get some
extra gifts from that shacks um
confectionery heart gift box thing and
yeah he was kind of wack to me man like
he didn't I was expecting the first time
I tried it when I was wid stone
he gave me like you know a masterwork or
enhancement core and then everything
else it was like blues and in a whole
bunch of other planetary material I'm
like what and I did it like four times I
wanted to basically get rid of that
currency since I was gonna be useless at
the end of the event yeah and yeah man
so um you know they didn't go too well
for me with that but I had a ton of fun
ton of fun with arm without what you
call the crimson days I think just goes
to show you and it's a competitive 2v2
mode sometimes people like it I had a
good partner and it was really cool some
good Randall we would just really
wrecking shop do an app touch a little
iron banner slight anthem not much I'm
saying I've really got a chance to play
since the new patch so I actually lean
on you and we get to that and uh you
know let's get into what we what we got
to talk about man yeah um we got got a
club at a place I'm going to talk about
which is a little bit of a change
sometimes yes
but the risk we kept Bungie came out and
of course the graphic at the top is the
Drifters crazy shipped on his we don't
know what the heck he's going crazy
taking planet ball of I really have no
idea so I'm very I'm honestly hopefully
curious we get to figure something out
when it comes to season of the Drifters
mmm just to know what the heck's going
on with them because like you know
questionable figure wants us to like get
all these little taken motes build up
his little energy ball like we're just
storing up some little battery for him
to cause the up I don't know idea so but
to get started we are nearing the end of
the season of the forge it's not like
the content is gonna go anywhere annual
pass will keep going but to wrap up this
season Bungie does want to do a raid a
lot when you're always cool nice you
haven't ever checked any of them out
before they are yeah really cool to
watch to get in the eyes of the raid
guys to see what they're talking about
when they go through an encounter what's
going on mm-hmm
the raids been out there for a couple
months now so if you're thinking
spoilers it's a little late for that
but yeah it'll be too
they favor 26 basically next reset and
it's 10 to 12 so Pacific time so for me
nice time for me to get a home and have
something to watch while I'm working on
some videos a little bit good absolutely
check this out yeah I definitely like
the three DeLong's and you know shout
the pyro he's a great guy and you know
it's really cool to see the thought
process to really see what that what the
mentality was and there's a couple of
sections I'm dying when they get to the
the the Indiana Jones part I call it yes
well you got to escape the evil serve it
on your Sparrow and it's pretty cool
graphic God good morning sir hope you're
doing well but um yeah so uh you know
I'm definitely forward to those are very
interesting to me rays are very
important you know to destiny and I love
hearing that commentary regarding yeah
so if you guys have never checked one of
these up before it will be live but if
you don't catch it live literally just
go to bungees youtube page later they
always post their stuff up so but I mean
you get to see like what their thoughts
in a fight are well how this boss came
to be some of the stuff in the
iterations they go through and these
things are kind of an analyst like you
get to see a little bit behind the
scenes of just like hey this boss used
to be this way the mechanics were this
way and then this accidental thing
happened when there was an interview I
can't remember what podcast or where I
saw it it was something with gambit and
like the primeval wasn't even a thing
for a while like it didn't even exist so
that's kind of one of those things
you're like I can't even picture game
without it so it's just interesting to
hear like stuff like that that would be
complete game-changer so check it out
what later though these are always tuned
in and forth mmm is he in the building
up early for his uh govision slander
keeping it all in check so no worries I
was catching up on my time in the iron
Lords podcast and that was rather
entertaining as well as talking talking
about that offline though those guys
were getting into it speaking of getting
into it alright alright alright
is our first tease for the season of The
Drifter mm-hmm and it's finally here now
we don't get a huge chunk of info but we
get a little bit they're working on some
quality of life improvements for gambit
since that is the overall focus and kind
of a season B drifters main piece so
senior designer Robbie Stephens speaking
on behalf of the team talking about a
couple things they wanted to do so these
are the changes that you can expect
probably some others as well full patch
notes he'll tell you what changes the
game but precedes of the drifter so they
want to address some of the top feedback
they've been talking about and probably
one of the biggest things I've been
hearing about isn't even listed here so
I'm really open they kind of touch on
some of that stuff later not
all-inclusive but like sitting here
thinking I was like I read through this
and then I'm like there's a big part we
didn't get but excuse me
so first thing change the third round of
gambit to a primeval rush sudden death
this is meetup games overall and add a
change of the pace of the final round
first off man what do you think of that
that's interesting I want to know how to
implement it um so basically they're
around but I see well I hear that the
terminology primeval rush sudden death
does that mean it's an automatic
primeval on what I have to assume yeah
you know I probably like load the round
and it may be just like me I don't know
if it's gonna go back or like he talks
you guys would be like are its primeval
rush time and we're gonna run out and
you go or if it's just like you know if
the round ends and it's you probably
have to go back talk to him but yeah I
think it's just gonna be straight-up
primeval spawned in and maybe there's a
tweak to it but yeah it's just know
collected motes just go at it I mean a
different type of a mechanic and I guess
a little tension I guess when I see that
kind of a thing it kind of puts me in a
you know the meatball has appeared
mentality it could be interesting
because you swimming like you said like
there won't be any moat gathering phase
right during that period it looks like
both of you out so um yeah I think this
is interesting I like the mindset behind
it I will say this I have to see how it
plays out but I like the mindset because
let's be honest much as I love gay
it Gabby matches below oh yeah if you go
and that's the thing is if you go to
three oh man it's like 25 minutes bro
half an hour for one you're like I'm
never gonna get the infamy I need sorry
I agree I think it may end up being a
good call yeah I'm willing to give this
a shot you know I know that this
actually fundamentally changes gambit
there's no doubt about it so um yeah we
have to see how it plays out but I think
my gut is telling me yeah this might be
a good call
so we'll see that's like you yeah I was
like I mean if you do still two rounds
organized you melt him down you'll never
even have to worry about the rush but I
mean if you go one-on-one just you know
speed through to I'll be curious I was
like I'm I like at least how it gives if
you you know if you go one and one you
like I had a really crappy first round
powered through got the next one you
know then you just like jump right into
the deep end and finish it up so that's
first piece overhauled how they choose
invader spawn locations and increase the
number of invaders spawn points on each
map extremely good yes I should greatly
reduce the chances of spawning very near
or directly on the sidelines of an enemy
Guardian so another big piece I don't
know about you I don't know if you've
ever liked invaded and been like instil
wiped or yeah yeah it sucks yeah that's
good that's good you definitely want to
fight and change on your invasion you
know and yeah listen fixing spawns
always affair so yeah I'm good with this
let's continue yeah now before we move
on though since we're talking about
invaders right now yes sir this is the
only thing they mentioned on invaders
and one of the biggest pieces mm-hmm the
people have had feedback on that does
not mention here and that's why I was
like I know this is not all encompassed
I can we talk to me is how the invader
is how powerful the invader is when they
come through you have the over shield
you're already extra powerful you have
the you know wallhack you know not
vision you look constantly and it's like
people are just like it's got it they
want some type of tweak so the invader
is not just able to wreck now they've
got some tweaks in the sandbox we'll
talk about a little bit later which
should help someone with this but still
just the fact that the invader has
overshield knows exactly where you are
still have the ability to like know when
you're gonna peek in things like that do
you I mean I haven't touched gambit that
much but just a related we played it
enough today with the like what are your
thoughts on changes that the invader
could like need to make it you know
either more balanced more fair is it
good as it is what do you think I might
surprise you I'm actually okay with it
the only reason why I guess is because I
mean let's be honest I mean if you just
look at it from a pure balanced
perspective it's still for v1 you know
yes he's coming in there with a little
armor and on you know the OSHA I make no
mistake yeah he's definitely tanky yeah
there's no doubt about it if they want
to tweak um the armor I guess cuz you
know I don't I wouldn't mind let's put
it this way I wouldn't be mom I wouldn't
mind if they tweaked his armor per se
and we be upset but kind of he kind of
needs an advantage on the invasion
because again if I know me when I when I
hear the invader has L on you feel like
I stop what I'm doing I get behind a
tree and I'm like wasy I'm gonna go get
him now
alright like literally like that's what
I do I mean I get that's my mentality
when I hear the drift assessment so
again coming think about if we're expert
level where you don't like the expert
low but we're above average and you play
that way Rayden gonna really have much
unless he's got one of those broken
weapons that we shall discuss mm later
if he has one of those Dana gets next
you know saying so you know I'm okay I'm
under the impression data you feel he
needs to be tweaked I mean that's just a
lot of the feedback I've heard over time
listening to the podcast seeing comments
out there on Twitter it is one of those
things a common one I've heard is either
it live one or the other whether it's a
lower shield whether it's I think one of
the big ones I've heard mostly is that
the vision through walls should be like
a pulse like so you know an idea where
to go you you had you're not just late I
mean there's a big map if I like start
on one side and I'm like looking around
me and I don't know where to go
does cannot say you only do have 30
seconds it's a short time other thing
you know I got he only has so only a 30
seconds and it's still for people if he
gets a bad spawn you know it's a tough
one I know what you're I'm not saying
your mindset wrong I hear what you're
going the person has an advantage he has
the wallhack he has he's tanky has that
Armour what I mean I could always be for
myself we don't when I and I've invaded
I don't invade a lot to be honest but
when I have invaded I've had times I'm
like damn I just do this like they had
me dead you know but I wouldn't I
wouldn't be upset either away if they
loans is not too heavy-handed nurse they
decide yeah I mean it's like the invader
needs to still feel like they can you
know make a swing in the game take
people out with modes like definitely
jump in there kill some people
hmm I mean I go there it's like if
you're going do you got decent heavy
drops you'll go across the side with
thunderlord or something like that you
can absolutely wreck some face like
machine guns I don't know if they're
gonna get touched I actually don't want
them to because I love how powerful they
are for the heavy weapons slot but man
machine guns are so powerful now I mean
you're not gonna hit as quick and
precise that ranges like a linear fusion
which we'll talk about in a little bit
but man I can just ruin some people with
underlord it's not even play it's not
even funny so that's one of those pieces
where I don't know like I just if they
don't touch what the invader is only
kind of curious if the game still feels
kind of say me I know they're touching
the sandbox I know they've got the
primeval rush but if game it doesn't
have too much of a change and we got
some other ones coming just the invasion
part I think needs some kind of tweak
you don't know it like something a
little more maybe something a little
less maybe you invade you have like at
least one bullet a heavy or you know if
you go through like it maybe recharges a
couple of your abilities or some I don't
know like so you feel the invaders
really powerful in your experience you
feel like the invader invader really is
doing a lot I'd like if I mean it's kind
of one of those things it
it depends and that's why I think the
spawns will be beneficial to almost help
not to much but really give you a chance
but if I have that chance and if I can
if I can get to the point where I push
them a little bit and I can drop like
one or two they get all Heidi in the
back and stuff like and I can just shut
them down for like 30 seconds mm-hmm
just for what like I mean whether it's
my pulse rifle my go figure that I love
like just picking people off from range
late especially if they're in the middle
of fight or anything just one or two
bullets with underlord they're done and
they don't even know what hit em they
can write they can't defend and that's
that is part of the invasion it's like
if you you know the invaders come in you
here you better get ready and then I've
had yeah that the team's like turtle in
and it's like that's hard to do
like if they turtle up and they go
nothing but just like all right come at
us we're a full group you're probably
gonna melt it if you get in there and
that's the point for you as the invader
to be like I'm just gonna hang out here
and I'm just gonna shut you down for a
little while we're just gonna be at a
stalemate but they can't do anything and
that's that's summed up just as powerful
as killing them just because they can't
do anything so I don't know it's like I
I know they've got changes I'm curious
to see if there are other changes that
come but I'm just surprised they didn't
even address it because it has been a
pretty predominant piece of feedback
I've heard interesting that's funny I
mean you you would know you know more
than me as far as you know the outcry of
the community on that aspect I really
don't like I said I'd much as I play
game but I don't really follow you know
I know I know that the things that I
heard the most were actually like melt
those melting the primeval strats and a
different one we'll get to rice Oh dad
I've heard that I heard people yelling
from the rooftops and stuff like that
but I really I'm learning anybody at
least from my experience you know hey
these invaders are out here unless it's
a unless it's in pertaining to a
specific weapon like the reign of the
sleeper now the reign of the Queen's
breaker you know it and so on and so
forth but let's see let's see what
happens
let's see the implemented Idol
production it means that players remain
dormant for too long will not receive
end of gamer awards or infamy points
I know that's one of those things where
they're not gonna get the infamy points
at the end of game rewards but like the
idol print if you lose a person in
gambit you're at such a disadvantage for
the ability to like pick up motes have
an extra person just shooting bullets
out there to get things to go if you
lose that person it really hurts yeah
absolutely I don't know and that's one
of those where you use if you don't
learn it a full which is I wear my
brother and I started the other day
which look hilarious because we actually
came back in one guys we were a two-man
group for a little while and you still
lost both matches Wow like paired we
were like you know we probably went
through the first deposit but just he
and I we had somebody come in for a
third they didn't really invade too hard
so they kind of let us like kind to do
okay and then we had a couple other
people join in primeval came in I
invaded slowed them down just enough my
brother went for the milk won the first
round the second one they didn't have a
chance and I was just like what just
happened yeah beasted but on the other
side like if you start with two or you
lose somebody and it's one of those
things where it's like they're always so
worried about you know infamy points or
awards or things like that like one of
those things where if you lose somebody
or it drops you should not have like say
a streak you know taking away if you win
cool if you don't don't lose your streak
little stuff like that that you know
would help will along with this like
idol protection you can't control
everything so don't put your team over
that it has somebody get you know lost
yeah absolutely
mm-hmm next one the triumph light versus
light which I actually don't know what
that is can now be progressed by killing
Oh killing guardians using a super not
just invaders yeah nobody invades with
supers anymore I sometimes do but most
people if you got heavy still probably
better that you know
so getting the dredgen title a little
better which is good and they still
haven't addressed the orangey part of
titles which is yeah that whole thing
that a little bit later here and then
the final piece is adjustments to
blocker types while I clear up my voice
here you want to take this first time
yeah annoys you
so adjustments a blocker ties by deposit
tear so the small blocker will be the
taking goblin elf then the previous
Fleet flaming so Alex what about I can't
pronounce night whatever feelings there
we go so uh huh more health and -
there's gonna be a goblin now so that's
interesting medium blocker taken captain
with more health in the previous night
that's gonna be interesting and large
blocker will be the takin night with
more health in the previous oka so the
ogre and Felix are out of there that's
it it's a wrap now now they when you put
that blocker in you're getting different
results so this is interesting he says
those changes arrival to season a
drifter to get you in for ready for the
change of seasons we're enabling triple
infini for the final week of season at
the forge and that's gonna be on the 26
so uh yeah I mean what do you feel about
that II like per se as far as the UM the
blocker types now changing yeah it's
kind of interesting it makes me wonder
it's like a five stack is gonna feel
pretty weak goblins of all things it's
not even like you have a captain so you
got a pretty good site and take taking
captain with them but more house with
more health and also the floating ball
of doom that's gonna get annoying yeah
refresh me now wow am i blanking on the
captain roller shield taking flying
black ball of doom
yeah we're in first room those are a
couple taken captain oh yeah yeah that's
gonna be annoying yeah so basically what
they what they're trying to do is
they're trying to encourage that tend to
you know 215 stack and a bigger deposit
what is it goblin gonna do see that's
the thing it feels like miss waited and
I don't know I agree I agree I don't
like like this goblin better be doing
something I mean and he's like I don't
know if he's got like a grenade launcher
or I mean I feel like what would be a
better fit would be a sniper
yeah Hobgoblin or a vandal one of those
two would give like the ranged fight
like getting back in there a bit harder
and they could do some more at range the
you know little beefier guy with health
of black floating ball is like that's
gonna suck what the Goblin feels like so
weak in comparison just like you know
but I guess also if you throw down four
or fives I'm like you know like a couple
of headshots with malfeasance and all
those guys are dead like I can't pick
with less health than the Phalanx
failings weren't that hard to kill if
you got around their shields yeah about
that
I mean yeah I don't know and it's just
one like it's not even like a pair yeah
it's like I mean if you're gonna do
something knowing put like four Saiyans
up there so then they start splitting
like crazy like that be small but if you
don't manage them then it would get bad
yeah that I could see almost more to
where like the potential could be there
if you don't manage your middle section
but you have a captain for the medium
with more health than the night the
night had a decent amount of health the
captain probably will have a shield if
it is a taking captain which most will
and then now you have a night without a
shield with more health in the ogre now
I hope the night on this one is actually
bigger which would be cool it's like a
big beefy dude walking around yeah
that'd be kind of fun but again what's
the night do is it a Boomer is it a mmm
they gotta be slower they had well what
it seems to me they were not happy with
the ogre you know say and fall intensive
purposes you kind of finesse to over
just a crit spot you know move around
get him out of there
you know I mean he just had a lot of
help right you just had no health but he
wasn't really hard to deal with per se
but um I think I get that mentality but
I'm back with you with the small blocker
I don't understand that
thought process because it's like to
meet you're just discouraging people
from doing a small block it's like they
don't want the small blocker to go down
because it's really useless like that's
not gonna stop the opposing team you
know
Godwin just walk up like it doesn't even
take like any substantial amount of ammo
to get rid of like if you're gonna go in
for you know a captain you're gonna have
to burn through some shotgun ammo or a
heavy if you're gonna take out the night
like that's gonna take something but mmm
yeah those five shots are they're really
trying to steer you away from that which
is
priest-king kings and build in crackdown
3 - I'm the building okay you are you're
killing me absolutely but we'll talk
about that later
so one thing about this does make me
wonder and kind of wish that like gambit
they have you know they're changing up
the small blockers to be certain things
I don't know that kind of strategies but
why does that why do the blockers always
have to be these sets things oh why are
they always just these three why can you
have sometimes they're over sometimes
they're night sometimes they're
captain's sometimes they're failing
sometimes they're goblins you have a lot
of enemy types why is it just three good
point like I mean if you want variety in
a game this is the season The Drifter
you're trying to beef this thing up I
mean give it a variety it's like that is
that is one of those pieces that makes
that a whole dynamic of gameplay
something that could be cool to watch
and unfortunately if it's just the same
three you don't have to adapt in the
moment yeah I agree I mean is that we
confirmed that these are the season of
The Drifter because I'm assuming didn't
they say this see The Drifter was gonna
have fundamental changes to game are
these set changes or just like some of
them I mean it seemed like everything
because there's more introductions next
week I don't know if it's like another
mode more quests or who knows what the
other stuff is gonna be we'll get that
next week but right now excuse me
this feels like a good chunk of it yes
maybe this is yeah I mean interesting
it's like okay you know it needs to be
more drastic I would like that random
enemy type on the block or like you said
yeah really cool I was definitely like
that you know and then just why
eliminate those other types completely
you know I'm saying so shot the Forte he
was like I guess they want you to be
intentionally with your bench yeah the
vibe I got for tasers that like yeah
they definitely they don't want you
running with the five notes it's just
going over there and like hi like they
want it to be about a banking situation
so we'll see she had to Chris covert d2
season of the nerve
oh my god actually chat right now yes I
don't know this is an interesting design
choice we shall see
yeah it's just kind of one of those that
it's will get to kind of thoughts on the
drifter stuff he's the director here in
just a little bit but yeah it's like it
feels like a missed opportunity
mostly I hopefully that piece I'm hoping
that these are not all the changes right
and these are just part of what they
intend to do it just seems like now it
says below is a sneak peak of changes we
made based on community's feedback
expect more details additional quaddle
of life changes for gambit when season
when it drops on the fist so there's
gonna be more in the patch notes but
honestly this tease is lacking in quite
a few things so and if they if they're
saying something pretty like firm saying
hey the blocker types are this that's
what it feels like
I mean feels like they're leaving at
least a big idea there on the table just
me though I'm with you man but yeah
triple infamy if you do want to grind
that stuff out before the changes happen
yeah it's up to you but if you're trying
to get titles or anything like that
definitely this is your time over the
course of next week which is the final
reset yeah I'm just trying to think
actually now like so like okay so I know
captain bigger night bigger but like
what do you have what would you have is
a small blocker what do you think like I
was cool I mean if they want to beef it
up I mean I felt like they didn't need
to get rid of the ogre like I'm not
gonna say put the ogre owner at the
small blocker boy like they could have
had the night as the first one you know
saying like I would have been cool with
Daddy tonight and um you know they're
from there keep the ogre is I guess the
middle and stuff like that to be honest
the main thing shot the king he's like
they need to be gambit great again the
main thing I like about the change
though as I do I'm a huge fan of round 3
sudden death
forget banking everyone has to kill you
know I like that because gambit
fundamentally as much as I
of the mode takes way too long
you never say so at least you get a two
round dominant matches over if it's not
and it goes to that sudden-death round
forget the motes it's up primary was up
you know you guys are invading on both
sides and it just becomes a quick you
know whatever just and like you know it
just made a good point as far as the UM
it's more blocker like I wouldn't say
fallen he's got a mob of fallen but I
would say like it should have been like
like a mob of the little goblins kind of
like how when you do on the first with
Kali you know you do Kali then you step
on the plates
the guy in our last wish raid and then
you know how they swarm you when you
move on from plate to plate yeah it
should be a bunch of hoes at least now
don't just give me one Goblin and be
like you know that's the only thing I
could think of what about you you know
as far as what you thinking about with
that yeah no I mean I kind of like the
idea of multiple small things that kind
of gives a little more variety if you
actually do dump a lot of small ones
that strategy is yeah you can probably
burn through them but if you have like
six eight you know enemies in the middle
spy on splitting sounds terrifying I
still hate those things bad memories on
some silent moments so that's a thing
but small blocker I would like yeah at
least like two goblins per cuz I feel
like one is so weak it's even it's not
worth anything like it should be there
should be something to it and if you did
too and you put eight goblins in the
middle it's still not that bad to manage
but it is gonna take you a second to
think okay eight shots coming at me that
could actually take a second or at least
make me think of how how open I want to
be if I've got eight bullets coming at
me yeah absolutely
I'm with you I'm gonna reserve I want to
go in on them like it's as light but I'm
gonna reserve judgment until we get that
full season adrift their patch list
changes because I'm hoping they're still
holding things back and this is just
kind of like a sneak preview or some
things kind of deal oh man some of the
ones on I said a bunch of exploding
thralls that cursed thrall is a pack of
a while sitting there now that would be
trouble later on like if you're sitting
there trying to burn down
boss and then shotgun on the box and all
of a sudden they like they drop a small
blocker and it's explode he throws and
it just clears all you guys out in the
mill even thinking that oh that will
work though it would be those you hear
that Samuel oh crap were there like
every time so also a bunch of acolytes
that start spawning the acolyte eyes as
well like you wait too long that's gonna
get like that could be acolytes a
vicious
oh man you go cuz with a shattered
throne you see them a lot in there and
it's like they're just they're all about
those acolyte eyes especially in that
first area of the Arabists like all the
different symbols and stuff and those
acolytes are just like III I like all
the time no yeah Forte's which she said
that's what they do at the final boss
for the shattered throne and Saiyans
everywhere man little gambit the
infinite forest yeah dizzy that's one
thing I'm really waiting on to see cuz
they said there's gonna be new gambit
Maps they definitely want to see some
variety in here that'd be kind of cool
so so yeah it was like that's a tease
for seasons and drift here at least for
gambit changes obviously not all
encompassing but it's a start so next
week we'll probably get like a Vidak I'm
guessing maybe some info on the twelve
about modes and patch notes is gonna be
everything that my favorite word next
next what's that mother sandbar I'm
gonna go ahead and just let you jump
into this one the sandbox action is all
yours so you know take it away sir
sandbox done man should loot the Bungie
you know I love me some sane box changes
all right well we got so alongside the
gambit quality of life changes our
sandbox team we find doing some weapon
archetypes to refresh the gameplay
experience and destiny to clap your
hands love to hear this the follow is a
following is a quick preview of some
changes coming with testing update to
point 2.0 with developer commentary from
sandbox designer victor anderson linear
fusion rifles these energy weapons have
dominated gambit from quite some time
that is true first came sleeper simulant
ninja
breaker we've made them less forgiving
so we can enjoy a change of pace so
linear fusion rifle aim-assist values
will receive an adjustment to reduce
effectiveness at very long ranges weak
crease breaker has high assist values by
default we discovered an issue which he
was not honoring aim assist values that
applied to other linear fusion rifles of
the same archetype this resulted in
Queens burger having over double the
intended aim assist in last point linear
fusion rifles will receive a 10% damage
increase in PvE
to compensate for the above changes he
bought that long okay I'm a being as
have been melted at I haven't been like
hardcore gambit a while but I know there
were times where for like a team was
organized or somebody was good with that
thing
it makes sense that it like the double
the aim assist is intended because I
mean I know people are skilled at these
guns I've watched the streamers of what
you people play and yeah it's like if
you pull one of those out and it just in
it works you're like damn I'm so good
with this thing looks like apparently
was like real good like over the top so
I mean and Sleeper was the same way it's
like you could shoot somebody in the toe
and all of a sudden they just vaporize
off the face of the planet you're like
bit much so but here's my real you
didn't feel it fatal
pinkie toe I can't work so those little
pieces I mean linear fusion rifles are
fun they're cool to use they take a
second in charge you kind of got a lead
you got a you know know where you're
trying to shoot because they do take a
second but in turn what they could do
cross map and as most of the time you
are cross mapped anyway they were really
powerful but here's my issue with this
and this is why there's sometimes where
separation of these two things probably
needs to happen they have to buff damage
in PvE because they're messing with aim
assist and they don't want them to feel
unpowered and they can't split tweak
these things mm-hmm and they have to
always have this
PVE pvp apparently now gambit like all
these different balances for these modes
and you get to a point where you're
worried about you know anything getting
out of hand so much they have to be like
okay well well nerf it down here so you
can't shoot as far but if you take into
PvE you get 10% more bonus but if you go
in a crucible it's just gonna feel weird
and blow up in your hands like it's just
those times were the whole system's they
have in place seems so interwoven right
I always wish there was a little more
you know they could compartmentalize
stuff a little better so I mean that's
always been you know destiny yeah that
that's always been the unfortunate
juggling act that they have to play
because of so many different modes and
you know I guess I'm I trust me you
heard this shout the bloody he's
actually a big you know person in the
community that as far as ohm I've had
him on ILP last week that he was a huge
st fan he went away from destiny and
this is one of the reasons and he was he
really hates that aspect like you know
if they do a par for a nerve how it
affects the other mon stuff like that
and I get it I think it's valid I don't
think anything he's saying is incorrect
for me it's one of those things where
it's just like I just love the fact the
game got all these boats so yeah for me
personally it's one of those things that
at least I like destiny to this go
around that I noticed that whenever they
make a change like this they're quick
they say oh but we're gonna buff it in
this we're gonna buff it this way in PvE
or we're gonna anything that affects one
they seem to be very they seem to nerf
buff in conjunction I'm noticing in
destiny too so far at least what I've
seen in the short term the last maybe
three months we've gotten a couple of
like Telesto right so I forgot hit hard
in people yeah but in PvE my boys are
telling me I think it was stolen or
somebody else I was talking to maybe um
scream or somebody that they will I go
to last I was crazy good at baby now
because of that buff you said I'm saying
so it's it's a fine line you know it's
it's never it's gonna be one of those
games unfortunate that's just the nature
of destiny that because
that way the sandbox is structured and
it goes across all the different modes
you know we're gonna have to deal with
that is it you know is it to some
people's liking not everyone not
everyone likes it to me I don't stress
this one as much but it's back to the
point with linear fusion yes this needed
to happen you know I warned everybody
after they was coming for my sleeper
Queen breaker was gonna have to get it
clean breakers got it I think aim-assist
is actually the key value because at the
end of the day it is long distance
it's those long-distance ridiculous you
know I mean it's that you know it has to
be more of a skill weapon you know I
mean as like a sniper a sniper is a
skill weapon if he gets that headshot he
deserved it give that man a round of
applause but I lose I lose just like I
love loot Linear's you know but let's be
real it's easy button definitely is here
for sure so you know this needed to
happen I'm not too crazy about it but um
that's what I got on that but we've been
getting to shotguns
yeah shotgun and the season of The
Drifter we are making a few changes to
rapid-fire shotguns and the full auto
perk we're doing this for a few reasons
one of them being that the full auto
perk feels far too important to shotguns
and PvE this perk effectively doubles
the damage output of any given shotgun
due to the rate of fire increase while
we believe it is important to have
useful perks on your weapons the FOC of
this was so impactful that rapid-fire
shotguns became the only shotguns worth
considering for PvE when the following
changes released in shock season of The
Drifter we hope you may have been
inspired you might be inspired to give
an aggressive shotgun or maybe even take
a slug shotgun damn haven't seen one of
those in a while
for for a spin in PvE activity so here
are said buffs and nerfs shotguns will
receive a damage multiply in PvE
activities effectively doubling their
damage legend Eve actresses legend
actress is an exception full auto rate
of fire bonus for shotguns is now plus
10% down from plus 100%
in addition that's
huge in addition it no longer increases
the shotgun pellet spread then we have
default rate of fire values for have
have also been shifted so aggressives
are 55 RPM they're up from 45 RPM
precision shotguns are 70 rpm up from 55
RPM light weights are 80 rpm they were
erroneously stated to be 90 RPM
previously and rapid-fire 140 RPM way
down from the 200 rpm and those are
previously natively 100 RPM but due to
the intrinsic full auto they really were
200 rpm and last two bullet points also
reduce damage for shotguns across the
board to align with their new rate of
fire on a per sub archetype basis and
lastly ammo reserves for shotguns were
re-evaluated due to the increased
efficiency of having more damage per
shot this is a lot to unpack what do you
feel about shotguns in general and was
any of this necessary in your opinion uh
I mean in people in PvE yeah Auto
like full out of shot ease they're
dealing me to go quit and pump out of
damage if you're gonna make the risk to
get in there yeah it's the only way to
go I'm not gonna go take a single shot
in there cuz it doesn't hit hard enough
over the course of time especially
compared to a full auto or it's just
like Bam Bam Bam Bam Bam
like whatever you tryin to go in there
and melt you can probably do it before
I'm gonna take a big chunk get in and
get out you can't take that one shot
there's no hardly precision bonuses if I
go put it one shotgun shot in the middle
of a night one's not gonna do much seven
from a full auto yeah that is a lot so
and actually I forgot one important part
underneath the bullets also took the
opportunity to slightly adjust shotguns
for the crucible while shotguns will
remain effective in the crucible we have
toned down the range and where shotguns
cuz you're a wood shot kill
since that man has to do again I'd bill
restive peaceful out lawfully man it's
like science so full auto going from a
hundred percent boost down to ten
percent hmm should we say r.i.p
escalation political shot good like
ichael oasiz gonna be I don't know like
I mean does have trench marrow still it
does have trans barrel so it's still
gonna get some more power but it's gonna
be not doo-doo-doo-doo like yeah me is
not gonna be there so yeah I mean this
and this is kind of one of those things
where I you can't always buff everything
for up forever right but also it's like
100 percent down to 10 percent you
completely shift the way that feels what
if it was 50 percent I guess maybe it's
not enough and they did their testing
which I'm sure they did now they said in
addition no longer increases the shotgun
pellet spread if you're full auto which
is a give and take so I mean they did
give something back there but 90 percent
speed reduction is up so much like then
you're at the point of is there much of
a point to it not really it depends it
depends I mean let's look at the
alternative I'm gonna give them some
crack the only reason why I'm I'm
curious
i think the trench barrel shotguns are
gonna be okay that's just my gut until i
we actually play i mean i'm just going
my gut I have no factual information
yeah but I will say this I gotta be
honest II like when EP shotgun was in my
position at other shotguns you know Finn
I don't you know energy weapons slug
shotguns I remember at one point shout
the Newmark he did he's in a chat they
had her one because we knew more aki
brothers but um yeah like they had a
good one and it was a slug shotgun and
he had a good roll I believe rampage or
something it was a Soros one good bro
instruct good bone structure kind of
similar in that line but he had one of
those new monarchy kind of names
unification 7 or
yeah I'm catching but um that that bad
boy was good you don't say and um so
it's gonna be good to say just you know
to see what's up you know shout they do
these in all hail head day overdue out
of here yes yeah that's my man we could
even the law with our man Dale but oh
yeah man so at the end of the day is
like I will say with aggressives going
up Precision's going up lightweights
going up and rpm you know cuz let's be
honest no shot ease folks know they felt
slow the handling felt slow so I'm
curious you know I'm saying we'll see
we'll see I mean I'm willing to give
this a shot because we do need a little
bit of weapon variety in in terms of
shotguns I just feel that like
everyone's out there if you're not out
there which EP you know you're out there
what you does rock you know what's the
other one you know it's like to sing
like no one's running them other shot
ease no one like I don't see them at all
maybe once in a while you get a parcel
of Stardust you ever say hey but that's
just again my experience what about your
experience with shotguns and what you
see I mean for me same thing as you're
saying like the foal out it was really
good because you felt you could get the
damage out to justify using that in the
PDE situation because the risk versus
reward and PvE is I'm up in the face of
so many things like too many things in
destiny smash they want a Hulk smash so
[Music]
just the fact that they're not buffing
the damage of any of the other slower
like the aggressives or the Precision's
like well that in PvE if I'm gonna get
in there and I still get like one slow
shot like you're not helping the
shotguns this was like shotguns were
useful in PvE cuz you could get that
damage dump of a full auto what I would
light of fire of some bring the damage
up of others so you actually have a
reason and even if you got a split it
they will sometimes split PvE and PvP so
make it if I go in there with like my
retold tail and I do one shot with that
thing have it hit like a truck
- are we missing something is it first
bullet let me go back our shotguns
receiving a damage multiplier in PvE
activities effectively doubling their
damage so are we getting this except for
a curious accuracy is insane accuracy
but if if the first bullet point is to
be true then I would assume this is
gonna apply to the rest right maybe I
mean I guess but also is like how much
they're like aid to a damage multiplier
we even you know we'll some of the
multipliers they throw out there this is
tiny
this is Bungie with their like that like
I don't do like a number of like
aggressives go 45 to 40 from 45 to 55
with a 50% damage buff like that's the
type of number I want to see in until
then I don't know if it's gonna be
enough I guess is more away it's not
that it's not there I guess I said that
wrong because what is more the fact that
I don't know if you're gonna justify
because again that full auto 7 8 shots
in that trench barrel go in there punch
Bam Bam Bam Bam Bam Bam Bam get out
while you reload and none of these are
still gonna have the capability to put
that much damage out and if the
multiplier is not high enough even if
these are slower it's gonna be a giant
sorry almost add something else language
sorry captain it needed to be a huge
buff to make it worthwhile because if I
go in there like one shot BAM that's it
and then I gotta like you know pump the
shotgun and then go back in for number
two it's it's gonna I mean maybe they're
just trying to bring other like energy
weapons in to be useful things like that
but I don't know I'll just have to see
what those final numbers are Christ I
still have my doubts it's gonna make me
want to go take a retold tale a
precision or heavy hitting slow slow
shotgun into anything in PvE that's
gonna be worthwhile I agree classic
Bungie where we don't we have these
arbitrary buff we don't know what the
specific God is like why can't they just
tell us what the specific damage
multiplier is you know maybe a chest it
but you know that's what we got all
shout scream good morning good morning
sir good morning yeah basically yeah
I'm actually happy about The Crucible
aspect mmm
as I'm dying to see how the range is
reduced because you know sometimes let's
be real like shotguns can get obnoxious
you know and they can't but man they
definitely don't all work the same
I don't retold I have a retold tale it's
new rated range masterwork yeah threat
detector I've got 91 range on the thing
and it is a precision frame and I've got
rifle barrel so increased range light
mag it's pretty solid and there are
times where I'm like okay I know I'm not
the best at PvP I'll watch myself play
I'm like yeah I have moments that I just
suck it's fine but there are moments
where I'm like okay you killed me with a
shotgun and I killed you and I'm pretty
sure mines got more range or at least as
much as anybody's out there and you
didn't kill me with like a perfectly
rolled play no dust crock losers like
whatever the you know the god rules are
the other one of retold tale you didn't
kill me with that yet I didn't kill you
sometimes back and forth just the figure
than that it's just it doesn't always
feel great
it's very inconsistent and and what
didn't shout to fall out plays he's
always said they said shotguns do have a
tendency to be inconsistent inconsistent
bottom I agree it's like I feel like
it's one of those things I'm totally
agree with you he's like you feel you
always get killed by it wouldn't can't
kill them with that same yes yeah I'm
just like I don't get it I think I'm
doing everything right like I don't have
that rate like it's just you know how I
feel that way with the chaperone people
are mad at me with the chaperone but I
and I'm like I am terrible with that gun
by the way like awful with the chaperone
like I'm just like I'm just I'm just
gonna throw this in it was just nothing
I clearly what I'm doing is wrong this
is not for me yeah whatever it is I'm
not doing it right that's what they got
so you want to take the tracer all right
so the other piece in the world of
changes and nerfs and supers and exotics
and they couldn't forget it so what I
mask has been too effective and become a
non choice exotic for Titans of PvP
after implementing implementing the
follow
Changez we believe the exotic will still
be potent if used well but there will be
more opportunities to counter it so
first this had to happen yes there's no
question about it
I didn't running loose come on now I
gotta give some of that nerf love
warlocks felt it last time
so the duration of mark of the vengeance
has been reduced from 15 seconds to 8 so
definitely shorter the way players
refill health after successful kill has
been changed before it restored all of
your health in the overshield refilled
over time now the health refills over
time alongside the overshield
this should give a leg up when
encountering situations where multiple
people are fighting one person with the
one-eyed mask mm-hmm so vengeance will
no longer trigger for players in super
this was making supers far too potent
that actually seems pretty fair supers
already have their moments of ups and
downs oh I mean it seems reasonable
just the fact you don't get that instant
refill if you see somebody kill somebody
and all of a sudden it's just like buff
over shield like Mike they're
untouchable like if they were running
around and then on the other side market
vengeance being shorter 15 seconds is a
long time so 8 seconds still put any
time to get work done most gunplay
between back and forth hiding in the
pillar still probably gonna take about
that long so it's just not gonna last
for you know half a day absolutely crazy
you get that man he was in trouble so I
mean we knew this was coming I don't
think they took it into the ground I
think they just kind of took a bit more
of the eye whipped cream and cherry on
top off the top of this thing and made
it just a normal ice cream sundae it
seems you still seem could be pretty
good but crate nerf they didn't kill it
so she'd be powerful yeah it's like
that's kind of thing now like this is
probably a little more reasonable
still as opposed to like the warlocks
Nova Nova work just like nerfed into the
ground and still effective like you said
not to cut you plays it's a nerf but
it's still useful and
my favorite part is 15 seconds to eight
that's why I think so it's like you you
can't just sit on it like 15 seconds is
still a lot to be running around and I'm
saying with that mark of vengeance kind
of I do like that aspect and um yeah you
know I said I think this is a fair nerve
I would say that unlike my novel
warlocks put your hands up you know
we're going out for the Nova works for
the Nova website there that's been
hurting but yeah I mean that's what I
got but yeah this is pretty fair I'll
keep it straight with that a new season
means a new reality in combat keep up
the cheddar will keep curating the
sandbox so that destiny adapts when you
the way you play and we'll just see and
be nice if we get you know we got at
least a couple sandbox changes fairly
closer here it'd be nice to see if these
were more frequent than alright we're at
least the meta let's say you know
analyze it for three months and then
right before the season of whatever the
next one is comes out then they do this
again like do it once a month once a
month is a reasonable pace where it
gives them some time and analyze and you
don't get it quite right you know you
can't always tweak but mmm
yeah it's just one of those things that
needs to be done faster too many other
people are too many other games are
making changes quicker they have to
definitely get on that train salute we
all know we're gonna get into a but we
gotta salute by where we got a salute
anthem like we don't already in a short
period of time and games technically
just launched what today
so it's like yeah man you see the the
the response time you see the reaction
you want Bungie to get on that cadence
you know I mean so absolutely they
definitely need to be there so if we get
them once a month big sandbox change and
you know in their defense the last two
swabs have been pretty yeah I was
shocked to see some stuff being changed
up so you know they got to keep that
cadence yeah but that's pretty much most
of the teases we've got we'll get more
info I'm sure keep your eyes out for a
viaduct Tuesday or Wednesday
I'm guessing could be wrong yeah but
they did it before
but we've got some things that will be
resolved finally right at the end of
season of the forge hey let's fix it now
some of this stuff and this is like the
top type of stuff like you got to be
able to make some of these Corrections
quicker especially when the things that
were like breaking quests and stuff like
that like those have got to be like
critical path things I'm getting that
from like anthem but the critical path
of like a quest line has to work like
people have multiple characters you need
to know that that is like that should
not have even been a thing like you get
on one you lock out another character
that that hold on I have to correct some
warlocks in the chat real quick oh hold
on you do that let me correct it
warlocks dizzy and my man Chris Cobra
Lee listen nice Chris Cobb really you
yeah that's a cool look that's cute what
you're doing with your wallet it's very
cute you're doing Nova with the viola
saves you but that's cute get on that
top tree oh please get on that top tree
with the slow ville with the buffs to
the Slover the Cataclysm and please
shout out three bonta's he sent me to
text you know I'm saying skull of donger
my car came out last Friday with sir so
but if you didn't have it now is the
time throw that on it is so cheap and it
feels so powerful like let me give you a
quick example I know this is a real
sidebar the Warlocks got me excited
right now yeah oh
what does strike Dom what's that strike
it's the UM it's a it's a cabal captain
it's on necess you have to do it as part
of you have to do a hard version on a
part of the Izanami Forge quest section
where you snow inside terminus yes you
stand inside and you stand aside and
you're waiting to charge up a plate and
they keep setting waves of enemies right
you have your super with skull and top
tree you you wipe them get you super
back wipe the next wave get you super
like I literally did for Novas I was
begging them for your yellow bars I'm
like where you're at who wants to smoke
trust me dizzy as much as I love
nezarakku
it's it's over nezarakku it was a nice
run it's still good it's still good I
was saying
that's a rack in um PvP but PvE don't
you dare run without if you're running
void lock don't you dare run outside
there without that skull now it's
because top tree Nova is disgusting rant
over we can continue with the twelve now
you're fine dropping knowledge out there
I said Fred's over there and chat stop
leaking this information I don't need to
run into more warlocks waffleh waffleh
say afraid head gotta keep it clean get
ya got a hold off if you got those
secrets like if somebody you know keep
it small if you hints if you guys
listened to the last word and you're a
warlock you know I show favoritism he's
not wrong I gotta show my boy some
favoritism yeah it's just it's really
it's really good it's so good so you
check that guide out where if you want
to mix it up uh yeah so come early March
5th obviously update to point 2.0 will
resolve quite a few things that they've
been working on also like the relics of
the Golden Age which is something quest
for Sturm so most things are gonna be
corrected which is good and then I guess
we'll figure out what the new things are
wrong come the next one if there's
anything hopefully there's less but
there's just certain things just there's
patches here for like things that have
some issues so I'm not gonna go into
passion notes per se on details there's
nothing too crucial a couple movies of
the week and that's mostly wraps it but
they said with 12 days before the season
The Drifter seems the heart hard at work
dotting the eyes and crossing the t's
before we go I wanted to share a quick
preview of something with the hunters
among you have been asking for if you
ever found yourself thinking it would be
awesome if I could see my entire cloak
when previewing shaders as we have some
good news for you update to point 2.0
we'll just make a slight change to your
view when inspecting cloaks in the
character screen that me yourself I had
that's gonna get too out of control I
was like you so loved you turned into a
police siren had to meet yourself yeah
that shout out to the hunters man yeah I
needed that yeah yeah that's what I'm
talking huh does a listen I'm a walleye
hunt is a
like Hudson's they I came very close to
picking hunter when I first that destiny
and this is the reason you see those
hoodies you see those designs you can't
you can't front warlocks they maybe they
be stylin they they really got a nice to
see that they can see this kind of stuff
it's good stuff man shout out to that to
the hunters out there yeah yeah I needed
this one respect but yeah I mean
actually it's cool but I love how this
is a tease they give so like it's real
small real subtle we'll have more patch
note previews leading up to see the
drifter until then have a great weekend
so all that being said how are you
feeling about season of The Drifter
listen man you know show up to Forte and
it's a he's a I forgot how to play
destiny hey oh listen is one of those
things that I just hope they don't take
an exact approach as they did to black
Armory and what I mean by the not saying
that black armor was bad you know as you
get through the contract loop you see
there's still a lot to do you know
weapons were cool raid was decent you
know we're not gonna have one with a
rating time you know but um I think this
is important I mean I don't want to
understate season of the drifters and
points because they need to do something
we all I lost my bet I thought it was
gonna be trials right so that's out the
window we've already got you know I'm
saying yep what a killing me to check it
out with you're right but oh yeah man so
it's one of them things we're just like
you know that's not coming you know
we're hoping that what we just heard
with the gambit changes is not it you
know we have rumors of thorn which is
good you know I'm with you II they need
to give some more story context with
with uh with drifter you know they can't
they can't give this thing to eat a
treatment we gotta like yeah books and
find out stuff do these erroneous side
quests and it's not like they got a
I think listen I'm gonna just keep it
real yo the backs up against the wall
for the summer that's just what it is we
got ant them out here
we got division coming you know I'm not
saying it's panic time but you've got to
get your core re-engaged you got to get
your core hype you need and then this
the other thing I'm a little nervous of
eat it's the last thing and I'll give it
to you post Activision right oh you're
opening a can of worms I wanted to get
into anyway so go for it okay cuz I jump
into this case oh yeah let's a little
nervous man because this is them on
their own and as much as we champion
this and we still think it was the right
move now you got to put on your big-boy
pants you got to advertise you got to
promote you've got to get people Pumped
Up for season and drift and I'ma be real
outside of us and everybody in this chat
that's last word both chats we're the
hardcore we're gonna be there but when
you speak to your friends and you look
at your friendlies
are they screaming season of The Drifter
yes they do do you see the big
advertisement push and again I know
we're not right at launch just yet so
I'm going to give them you know the
benefit of doubt and hopefully they do
their twitch streams and all that stuff
but they can't play around because right
now man and I guess the anthem is and
they think about an Edith anthem we're
gonna touch it with the rocky star then
we gonna get it wrong I can go too deep
anthem it's very responsive by the way I
should say they couldn't they're quick
okay you didn't like that phone we're
gonna fix it oh you like that okay but
we're gonna fix that if they keep that
cadence and get it everything to what
everybody wants exactly how they want oh
I'll give it to you I'm a little
concerned I'm not gonna lie this table
not saying that this was opposed to be
the end-all table to be like yeah we're
back baby now yeah but you know we
should be getting tight you know and
we'll see we'll see man let's see what
do you feel ma'am I overreacting do you
no no not at all
yeah I was like no word agreement on
this one shoutout to DCP last night I
caught like the tail end of that they
were talking about this a little bit too
and it's just something we've talked
about before and it is what is the
future of this franchise now that Bungie
is on its own
they don't have Activision forcing them
to a date which can have some benefits
but also in turn there's this expected
cadence of releases and September is is
a big deal we have a three which is June
which is usually where we get some type
of announcement some type of trailer
spoiler alert
that's where Kaede got shot like that
was that was a big deal but those are
big times whether it's rise of iron
taken King forsaken those were all those
moments that kept destiny is like hey
it's still here we've got another year
of this game some people love it some
people hate it but it's been there in it
and check one quick point did you just
made me think about something I forgot
remember you would you just nailed it II
put it in the mindset remember last year
where was the Kade trailer revealed on
the Sony stage yeah
Sony is not at e3 right
what Activision doesn't have a show so
does that mean destiny miss misses the
marketing cadence you and I mean and we
gotta say unless they do what they did
last year and kind of do a blowout do a
whole bunch of twitch streams on their
own but that's a key part I'll give it
back to you guys already I just made me
think of the whole when you said about
the Cade part you made me think about
that but yeah continue with what you
were saying yeah so I mean it's like
it's what did they do and there was a
debate going back and forth and I think
you and I probably had the same one
Stephani moment last night and you and I
probably said the same thing there's a
point where Activision had this schedule
you got to do this you got to put
something else that they were forced
sometimes okay sometimes really good
with forsaken sometimes things delayed
but we've definitely seen many moments
to where the schedule has been to their
detriment either because they
needed change they didn't get time to
really fix them they didn't get to put
all the things they wanted in there they
weren't ready for destiny to so rise
Virant was smaller like or taking king
but then you have this other like ain't
like giant like lag of content so this
schedule has been something that while
the the releases potentially have some
really good moments to them the lag
behind them has been an issue mm-hm and
now there's no pressure that someone you
know Activision is not knocking on the
door saying hey September 5th is coming
up we got to go ahead and get this stuff
what do we got so you can it's nobody's
doing that so it's really on to them to
decide and this is gonna be their
biggest decision probably when they made
this split and Pete Parsons and
everybody else at the top Luke Smith
trying to decide is there a major
release this year an annual pass cuz the
Annual Pass has been lackluster so far
as you said I mean black armory has some
decent moments if you go through and do
some of the trim the mysterious box and
stuff like that you get a little extra
tidbits but again you go through and you
play at them I pick up like a piece of
the cortex for lore I read it right on
screen I don't just like little tiny
tidbit and then maybe I can go find it
and some of the stuff more is in there
and the game but it literally pops up on
my screen
look at this click through it the text
is in front of your face not hey here's
a tribe or here's like a little text you
can go pull it up in a menu two slots
later right they're getting more of that
stuff in the game but in turn it's been
very minimal on story gambits i have no
idea what they're gonna do here and
honestly i don't expect a lot which is
sad but i don't yeah i mean even with
previous expectations we might get a
little bit of voiceover couple lines
with lines when we talk to him a little
bit probably just as much when we do the
malfeasance quest no I don't expect a
high you know high level or a very deep
piece of content forces in The Drifter
honestly I think this will be the
smallest of everything Wow yeah and you
may be ready look at look at what we got
on the docket I mean and it's the timing
which would not be
not be stupid to be the smallest like
enough to be like hey game it's kind of
fun yeah I know these games are out
there let the hype on these games go
down for a couple months because if it's
gonna start March 5th division 2 is
March 15 ten days later I mean that's
gonna take pull people over you got a
full campaign to go through you got the
end game then maybe you can figure out
what you're gonna do for season of the
redacted right and that's gonna be your
time to try and figure out what your
pieces are gonna be but I mean that's
gonna be June July and August that is
June III is early June all of that stuff
comes together right then and then June
July August you get to know what your
season of the reduct is gonna be and
then III is when we get our answer right
there about what the future of this
franchise is if it's major or if it's
minor this year and if it's minor do you
think if they don't release something
substantial whether it's even a rise of
iron size thing and what that would do
to this game or the franchise I
completely agree with you and I'm glad
you said it because I didn't want to say
it um I mean shout out to em beans in a
chat any nice and remember anthems DLC
start to drop in March also division
drops in March you know um
did this is these are a lot regardless
of quality or what destiny players may
feel about both games if they don't like
them it still takes away from your base
and this is critical they have to still
remind people why Dave's people should
play this game so this is very critical
season adept is very critical sees
another redacted very critical but um
yeah I think it starts with season a
drifter like you know yeah you can show
a thorn and you know like my thing is
this if they pull what they pulled with
season of the forge by just you know at
the end yeah that's where it's coming
that's not gonna be enough that's not
gonna be enough I don't think I don't
think if they just do a cute little
trailer and they show thorns against the
wall and you know na fan people gonna be
like that's cute that's cool I'll log in
that week
[Laughter]
yeah I mean it's in that timing we're
like anthem will come now people burned
it for a little bit you might have that
like week or two when some stuff will be
going but also I mean they have the
weekly Joker's wild quest and stuff like
that going on pull it up on screen so
you guys can see so you have your
Joker's wild weapons in gear Joker's
wild weekly quest one exotic and one
everyone's exotic but other than that
you have new matches and prey of new
maps and a power level increase
everything else is basic stuff that's
always there so it's literally like a
weekly quest whatever the game but
experiences which is still gambit you
have some bounties and you have some new
maps and you have a way to grind for
more power which is still more of the
same stuff this is the smallest of
everything to give you new things to do
is what it feels like and it hurts no
raid and in that's what they do man
regardless to the you know that's just
what they got like one thing I realized
looking at these other looter shooters
Bungie just know how to do a damn ray
BAE like they just you know it's the
structure of their game you know but um
you know but we got to see we got to see
they they've got to come up almost I
think they almost gotta come up with
like whisper level kind of stuff you
know this would be a good time to get
that hype of some secret thing that
drops it pulls people in like if they
find a release when they look at anthem
and division be like okay anthem is
doing its thing it's got attacked one
and then you got division coming out the
raid might be a week later okay so
sometime mid-april after a little bit of
settling in hey let's drop this secret
yeah oh let me ask you a funny question
but do you think something like
Gjallarhorn oh my god it's back in black
you would have to I mean what color they
did black already that was literally
like its thing when it returned if you
brought Gjallarhorn back mate you would
get people back for a little bit for
loving man but you would also get a
whole bunch of crap for doing another
old gun and they've done so many now
yeah I mean sleeper was a quest in
itself and that's a gun we had
previously Queens breaker was literally
Queen breakers bow I mean you have a lot
of things that you know you lost your
inventory and now we're whittling them
all back into like you know slotting
them in here here here here here there
putting them back in whisper was like
amazingly done and I love that piece but
I don't want them to keep doing that I
don't want Gjallarhorn brow back and
unfortunately like it would either have
to be so broken that it would be like
the only thing everybody uses and
they're kind of pissed off at that again
but rocket launchers aren't in a great
slot so so good would have the offense
out to duty checkers I know he loves to
get low he's like give me the baller
horn
he's going in hey I know that's his
favorite and I will say this based on
the way to meta is if they made if they
broke galley back how underlord is where
it's like just beyond all belief you
just melted people would get hype i must
admit as much as i would you eat i don't
want it back right now i really know but
not no hate on it it's just more of a
stop recycling the old stuff you know
kind of thing making new stuff you know
cuz to me Gjallarhorn is a win button
everybody's got the nostalgia everybody
but the equipment i have to be honest
with myself to and this is what kind of
leads me to Dizzy's point is that maybe
it is kind of beat it right now because
you know they got to do something
because people to play the king during
this kind of a transitionary period
between season of the redacted and then
hopefully um a September content drop
because we don't even know if that's
happening let's be honest we still don't
know you know post Activision world they
are not beholden to the September
release cadence at Activision had the
gun to their head because let's be clear
activision set that for a reason
September was so that destiny could stay
away from call of duty let's keep it
real because Call of Duty was always
November
I really dropped anything so they like
destiny had two months to breathe
October no I mean November was almost
what seat was card you know but we'll
see shot the l-boogie she said maybe
they are just in a struggle parent for a
little bit I think you will see recycled
stuff until they have a better direction
at this season of the redacted it's true
I guess my question to the both chats or
do you think come after season of the
redacted right they just I say we're
just going to gonna take their lumps
what we see on this map is exactly what
we get both chassis bondage at now P do
you guys think after season of the
redacted that they're going to keep the
September release schedule you know do
you guys think that and if not could
they survive without it
you know like tell me you're stealing my
question out of my mouth but alright
literally what I was gonna ask you
didn't telepathically think that's what
we do know you're in my head man now let
me pray let me preface this and I'm
gonna answer it in two ways mm-hmm what
I want is it not to be sucked and I do
not want a full release in September mmm
what I want now let me tell you why is
because I want them to take they time to
either do destiny either three or
whatever word comes next and if they
give the changes they were we were
hearing about Ford III a little more RPG
stuff in there more numbers more those
types of things I want them to do that
right and that's that that's the game I
want now they have that they're not
forced but also they have to keep the
lights on so how you do that so in turn
is it is it another annual pass where it
is like lackluster sales maybe the
die-hard stay around if they can kind of
find some you know a live team and a set
of things that will keep people around
enough keep it you know half relevant
the mind and give yourself time to have
90 percent of your entire staff and
studio focused on
that next big 2020 ps5 xbox two giant
release to go something like that big as
opposed to trying to split development
put it all into that this decisions
already been made we're speculating on
something they've already decided on
that's the yes I agree yeah I was like
they know what they're doing we just all
get to speculate figure out in hope but
yet just right they're gaming 40-date d3
2020 and when he's but that's and that's
the other piece like dizzy saying it's
who they can't afford to and it's like
they don't have the money they we don't
know what they're we don't know how much
money they have we don't know if
Nettie's bottom that year with that
hundred million I honestly don't know
but I was like my prep that's my
preference like they need to make sure
to keep the lights on and they're not
stupid enough not to but in turn I don't
want them to force a piece of content
pull away from time because they don't
have Vicarious Visions they don't have
hi moon anymore it is all them and I
want d3 to be what we all have hoped for
for five or six years so okay what about
this let me let me give you an option
today we do both but in a certain kind
of a way it's that we do after season to
redact it and we drop a comic level DLC
in September again okay so comment is
forsaken or taken King those are both
not reservoir those are bigger
give us another comment right now
instead after we drop comet let's just
say then they do what you want right
what's normal release structure will be
comment and then come you know December
would be there slash cursor Osiris /
black armory kind of a thing and then
you know make basing and that kind of
like that season pass structure what if
the comet is the last one and then it's
like okay nothing ear up for 2020 d3
right what if they do that would because
I'm gonna be honest you II you're right
they do need to take time and and really
make quality content but I'm with dizzy
they cannot afford to go quiet right now
they have to keep people reminding them
about this game
if you go quiet right now when you get
to biggest competitors are we about to
talk about the rest of the last word I'm
scared to death I'm terrified you can't
let them have the mind shake you you
always have to throw your hand to pay me
to remember me yeah because if you go
okay let me let me I'm gonna interrupt
you and I'm sorry if you keep throwing
your hand up but you don't have a whole
lot to offer what are you saying about
your brand if you keep saying hey look
at me look at me and then they look at
you and learn like well what do you have
you have a little past like I don't what
if they don't care if you're looking at
you
if it's not there what if it's like hey
I'm gonna let these two other heavy
hitters Duke it out for a little anthem
division going back and forth testes
gonna have some holdouts and then you
come back and you walk in like in you
know the start of a wrestling man I'm
not even a wrestler but you walk in like
a wrestling match d3 we here next-gen
and do it big like you let the d2 settle
down because honestly people have been
burned twice on destiny d1 year 1 d2
year 1 forsaken have been great but you
lost a lot of people on d2 giving some
breathing room and space in there has a
chance for it too late you know let some
of that step back let people learn and
as long as they don't pull a d2 screw up
and say hey let's completely change what
works and then come back in with d3 to
be like make the big announcement you
have a chance to separate from d2 year
one and say hey guess what or finally
doing this on our own and we did it how
we want to this is it and that's hoping
but again like I am honestly okay
because I have so many games that I
would love to play so here's the problem
see you will looking at it from the
gamer perspective right the gamer
perspective is that we've got too much
to play so theoretically we could be
like take your time right because we got
all this other stuff to play the problem
is the hardcore are going to come back
the casuals are not loyal like the
casuals grow up I'm telling you right
now is
now I understand your point about
raising your hand and then you really
don't got much I hear you on that but
you've got it who said it in shout-out
to your chest
Siegfried site said free said foreign
said Fred sorry yeah actually because I
what I see if they exceed freed of soul
calibur because it looks the same
Otto anyway so he actually made a point
that I agree with which was like they
need to make a hit before they even
think about announcing d3
if you announce d3 now with the stuff
that has come out - forsaking the sale
is gonna be a chore that's how I feel
like they gotta have one more banger
like a forsaken kind of banger to get
everybody galvanized again I think you
can't walk away on your worst kind of a
content now I'm not saying black armory
is the worst thing to ever play that
ain't curse of Osiris we know that but
it also could set the world on fire
let's keep it true it had a bad launch a
bad onboarding you know once you finally
end then you kind of understood it but
then you know rehashed exotic with the
last word raid was okay he wasn't you
know super great vagabond oh I disagree
with you brother division - listen man
you saying division - will not take away
destiny I say that because division did
not oh you are I Love You Father you
know you my god
you know you man I love you to death
[ __ ] up I know but you're definitely
wrong on this one because when Division
1 launched that literally not only did
it break records for the highest-selling
new IP that previously destiny had right
they started off with a bang they stole
that base and again regardless of
whether the destiny fans don't like
division that has a strong base and I
can see it happened anthem slowly doing
it right now
so again this is just me maybe I'm
worried wording a little bit too much
but um I need a comment man I need a
comment I need a I need something
forsaken level taking king level to get
the juices flowing to get everybody go
okay we're here now if they want to take
the break and it suggests after that now
do anything and then focus on d3 I'm
okay with that but just ended on a nice
positive thing to show that also you
know what you also need to eat now it's
my last point I know I'm talking about
no we both have it sorry you've got to
prove that you Bungie can do it on your
own on that level that's another thing
like you you you leave with this drifter
xandred active if no disrespected or
daddy we don't know what it is
my apologies reject I'm gonna be
disrespectful we just don't know what
you are robot ninja man but let's be
honest is Season Of The Drifter chat
getting your blood boiling easy I mean I
can answer the question forum they
haven't talked about it they haven't
talked about season The Drifter and it's
like this weird quiet non hype cycle
that they're doing they did the same
thing for black armory and I was
honestly wondering I was asking you was
like did they do the same did they
hardly talk about like a week before hey
here's this like this one will launch
and then they finally came out with a
graphic of like this on this date this
on this date this on this date we even
had that at some point I feel like
probably now two weeks before we
probably had the dates of when things
we're gonna start dropping
maybe we'll get that stuff next week but
we don't even have dates of what the
hell is coming yeah I remember let's
take it so got a weekly quest Zura
bounties and a new gambit quote
experience so maybe you'll have like a
gambit
you know submenu on the director but
outside of that I see three things mmm
everyman a power increase in which some
people are just tired of grinding up to
then it makes power level on three
characters it remember how upset you
were put your mindset back into launch
of black two weeks before launch of
black armory you said you used to pester
me I got it now you're I gotta give it
back to you were right
you were like hawk where's the where's
the trailer where's the height we know
this thing's about to launch we don't
even know what it is mama day they were
forsaken was still in the air and forge
was comin and we were like what thought
you were like your what is Forge doing
we don't even know and I was calm you
down you was like oh when are we gonna
get it and I'm like you know what they
kind of doing this same thing again with
just this like trip is about to be here
I could tell you I couldn't tell you
what's happening was I
gambits revamp yeah you know this I
don't know so I know some people it's
like y'all work on getting with
characters up to 700 or the nightfall
modify like is the nightfall score
amount if I are gonna change um we're
not getting strikes Oh crews all the
maps I don't even see them listed are we
getting vendor refresh is even late
that's the type of stuff that shouldn't
be not a designer so speaking out of my
rear end but yeah vendor refresh is keep
bringing it back some more year one guns
they at least have Joker's wild weapons
in gear but if it's like just stuff in
gambit like we have a lot of non so many
repetitions now like I am kind of good
on my 6,000 smugglers word I mean some
of that stuff is just like gettin old
whether it's you know a bad reputation
or some of these things that you go do
and yeah it's like some of the black
armor ones have some decent perks on it
but just like even stuff about tweaking
and this is where I wonder where their
resources are at like how can you hires
an annual pass we don't know if it
doesn't come out that great we might
burn people we might not even be able to
sell one again but we're sure as hell
not trying to set us up to have a chance
to sell one again because we're not
making it all that amazing it's like hey
this time we got they even even dropped
like new mods we got like four but even
new weapon perks or curate some of the
ones just like some of the things be
like hey snipers are no I'm gonna have
hip fire on there mm-hmm that's one of
those that just I'm like ah little stuff
like that to be like hey these changes
like quality of life you know here's the
new thing to grind for they had the
deserve all if I was gonna grind up for
a nightfall you know your nightfall you
know top to your thing was gonna be
there now it was just a quest that once
you have it you have it there's no like
hey grant out your Season 5 scores or
season six scores to get this new weapon
give me more incentive to do night falls
like not even updating the strike
exclusives because we have no strikes
maybe you throw a piece of armor in
there or something like they have added
there's so little value add on some of
this stuff I wonder
again I don't know where it's all that
but they got to be working on something
that's why I wonder what it is so very
curious man it's interesting times
interesting I like I like this type of
discussion because um you know we got to
see how this thing plays out we got to
see what they do and um it is very
interesting I'm very very interested man
but uh that's all I got
oh that's Ivy's but uh finished up the
drive we gonna get into this other thing
that we gotta talk about yeah so destiny
is not the only game and honestly it's
not a bad thing because it's kind of
nice to have a little variety but
they're just they definitely and this is
why we're wondering about what is their
answer what is their future because
there's a couple of the games one of
them launched at midnight wherever you
live it was still midnight I think
everywhere called Antrim yes I've been
playing it for the past week on PC and
they you got to play it like maybe a day
I don't think you've got to play it that
much at all have you watch man this week
as you know I've been knee-deep in a
certain certain projects so like I said
I literally got to touch it maybe once
or twice but I didn't get a chance to
touch post patch and I'm dying to get
your perspective because we do know
obviously the initial reviews were a
little shaky
[Laughter]
coding you guys cuz I can come in here
with my I told you so jacket but I'm not
doing that oh you can say I told you so
there's differences of opinion that's
fine not doing that I don't like to pile
on I think it's very apparent what has
been happening you know especially the
YouTube community and the the Metacritic
score of anthem is not good right now
let's just keep it true and one thing
that we've seen is they you know
basically one of the major complaints
we've seen is like loading times and you
know things of that nature as far as
quest rupture and you know things
happening in quests and stuff like that
an end game so I'm gonna give it to you
which is you know the infamous day one
patch you know you it's out in the wild
you've experienced it now you know how
much
this do you think has really you know
helped your experience and do you notice
a significant change well I feel they
got a couple things out that help smooth
out the the Big Lunch
mm-hmm you had the early access which
was I mean it's early access it's fine
it should have been full game but
literally said full game on their little
chart they weren't quite done and this
is a point where before I go into any
and all of this is you have to look at
the forcing of a publisher to say this
is your date hell or high water this is
one of those things Bungie doesn't have
to do now which has its ups and downs if
there's a point where they're like hey
we're gonna release it so-and-so and
then they're like no we will have a day
one patch we got a little more testing
dude doesn't quite feel right we're
gonna bump in a month mm-hmm this is one
of those things for Anthem probably
should have happened but EA said no it's
going now mm-hmm
and I think I mean everybody bashes on
EA good bad or otherwise they have their
ups and downs they put a lot of sports
games they still make plenty of money
and they sadly got their hand slapped
hardcore like with a ruler when they
messed with Star Wars Battlefront to the
loot box is completely breaking it and
then they've stepped back on some of
that stuff Activision unfortunately
going the other way but that's different
problem but you have anthem you also
have Bioware behind this people who do
want to do story and I shout out again
I've said it before the producers the
community like correspondent people
before anthem have been absolutely
amazing shout out to all of them pin
irving michael gamble and those are the
two i know there's the main community
guy i'm probably blinking on his name so
i want to say it wrong guys have been
mark mark Daraa mark dar is another one
and I swear there's a quarry no see I
know I was wrong well yeah it's the
activity I've seen since following those
people on Twitter finding their names
and actually seeing how much they do
they are so fast and responsive there's
a point where they found a farming
in-game farming glitch kind of thing of
a loot cave basically a chest run fixed
in a day nice play
now the loot caves yeah I mean the loot
cave definitely sat there for a little
while mm-hmm
this was fixed in basically as soon as I
saw the videos coming up it was like
done and fixed that night now it all
depends on how your game is built what
they can do but they were like yeah this
is going
no questions it's happening and they
fixed it
there is a I'm not gonna spoil what the
questline is but there is a shift in the
quest line where you have certain
activities you need to go do they ease
that one up a whole bunch made that one
a lot better not quite the wall that it
was for some huge fix definitely before
the big launch I'll say big launch early
launch dead matter but yes the big
global all consoles lunch
that was fixed before now were those
things that probably could have been
fixed before the 15th what I started
playing yeah loading times things like
that now this is the point where me
playing on a powerful PC helps on
certain things mm-hmm I didn't
experience as many crashes that's
honestly just crossed my fingers I had
more crashes in the division beta than
I've had an anthem mostly I mean that
was just like that and but they but
shout out the vision that was also fixed
in a day and then it like whether the
audio bugs were one thing the crashes
were done in a day two on ant on
division which was like awesome job guys
like can you please reveal to the people
uh what's kind of hard drive you have oh
about as good as they get in the I have
a SSD to the max I have an nvme so I've
same son 970 Evo so about a commoner
that that the common folk has been
struggling about you those which say
well in the world of common folk can we
get King in here and see is his Telecom
and by the way I about fell out of my
car listening to him talk about that
anyway so things they have fixed so
there are a lot of things people have
issues with this loading screens are
everywhere that needs some help
mmm-hmm absolutely still does they have
improved the loading times and a lot of
places that is live that's a big one so
that one's pretty big try to think what
else
just the high-level fixes and stuff like
that but just like my feeling of the
smoothness of gameplay being dropped in
things like that I haven't had that mini
I also haven't been like barreling
through the game as fast as some and
again how fast you want to play a game
to can could determine how much you
enjoy it there are certain things like
the voice acting the quests and stuff
that have been fun like I've really
enjoyed what and this is one of those
things shout out to Paul Tassie having
people to talk to and actually having
dialogue whether it matters or not it's
not Mass Effect you're not really making
decisions that have weight sadly kind of
wish they did more but at least having
decisions different voice lines learning
about some backstory of these characters
actually get something not all of them
are great but a decent amount like
better than destiny by about a
hundredfold I would love to like talk to
zeevala and then him going to this
random story about this time we were on
the wall defending it against these
fallen oh yeah back to your quest sorry
I'll see you later just those little
tidbits would be so cool so I mean there
are and I guess I'll preface this and
this is like if I do a thoughts video
it's gonna probably be titled something
like this it is a flawed but fun game
that's fair that sounds like I am NOT
gonna defend perfection on this game
because it's not there are things from
what I like from the open bay from the
open beta from the Alpha from things
that I've wanted fixed and there's
things that continue to like be worked
on and they still have them to work on
but my fun the Ironman simulator the
lightning strike of a storm feels they
nailed certain things in this game that
for me are fun and again it's not for
everybody if you love the tactical cover
shooter this is literally the wrong game
for you but I'll absolutely agree like
if you love the military boots on the
ground tactics you know working on those
guys like you go over here cool if you
love throwing like an ice bomb casting
down stuff within the sky be in a
interceptor ninja like yeah you're gonna
have some fun so all of that being said
that's like my general thoughts on it so
far I wish it had more time to bake in
the oven because it was like taking
bread taking a cheesecake out
like 20 minutes too soon didn't get a
chance to set didn't get a chance to
cool didn't get a chance to cool
overnight needed just some needed some
polish needed some it needed like a
bigger test audience to like iron out
some of the little stuff right oh
absolutely absolutely it that dad that's
my manager I mean listen at the end of
the day you know we care talk about the
you know the elephant in the room which
is ei right and we do know you know
shelter JC Schreyer he's mixing
reporting in reference to to crunch
these guys are under and as far as to
release cadence we know there was an
initial delay last year and I was
supposed to drop last year right and
then they pushed it out and you know
listen I'll be I'll be completely honest
with you II I am NOT an anthem hater I
know maybe last the last last word they
may have come off my collars no we were
like I'm fun banter yeah I didn't end it
that way
I want to shout carboxyl cuz I know me
and him go at it sometimes too but um
you know it's one of those things was
like I'm a person that wants this game
to succeed like I am hardcore like
that's one of my favorite devs in gaming
you know saying I grew up with the Mass
Effect series I love dragons a you know
I'm saying like so if anybody wants them
to win and you got understand tooth this
game doesn't succeed so if you're a
Bioware fan you know there are
complications here consequences here
that based on the track record of EA
which is known to destroy studios
sometimes and like this thing needs to
succeed so to see them fighting back you
know not gonna say that the wounds were
excel fit flicked it but whatever issues
they were having cuz clearly the game
had issues we cannot understate that you
know you know disappearing moms the
loading trucks too many loading screens
too much going on with that you know for
Tarsus a little too slow and stuff like
that but like you said when you get out
in an expedition you get out in the
world and you just fly you just shoot
and you just do your weapon and you get
you're doing your bills and you're
you're customizing things that's gonna
that's gonna work on certain abilities
it feels good and I tell all my destiny
fans even after my division fans like
regardless to the flaws just like you
said the foundation is fun right of
course I will always get in the end game
we're gonna win gonna make this the end
game show right now cuz we've already
done that collision coming up oh that
you know it's just like I said long as
they keep it up long as they keep up the
contents they stay on top of things stay
with the cadence they'll be okay they'll
be okay cuz I think a lot of people
still enjoying experience shout to
Eric's gaming he put out a good video
still enjoying it despite you know I
know there's an angry man let me be
clear though I want to say one last
thing about this people nah I don't feel
like everyone is hating on anthem I do
feel that some people are benefiting off
the negative press and then come out I
was like yeah it was like there's some
people just ripping it let's be true
there's a lot of things is broken
hey you're not wrong either so what
problem I have with people just saying
people are hating on anthem see people
like oh you're a destiny guy how can you
hate on and they didn't have a lot of
things but here's the fundamental
difference I was actually gonna save
this point for ILP on Sunday the
fundamental difference is that when
destiny one vanilla launch there were no
technical issues there was no infinite
loading there were no broken gameplay
aspects the issue came content right you
felt that there wasn't a lot of content
in destiny one and they felt that yo
where's this great story that I thought
I was promised that was destiny one
vanilla experience the anthem is
different anthem is like no how come
it's loading how come it's this how come
it's dead this is not working that's not
working I can't get in so that we have
to be clear that people who are destiny
fans that are attacking it or people
were just in general that are attacking
it we have to be honest that there are a
lot of technical issues out there
resolving it we've got this day one
patch I can't wait to jump in and see
what it's about Thank You Philly ego for
conceding it and you know listen man
like I said I want to be clear I want
anthem to succeed I do not want this
game to fail
Bioware is my favorite if they go away
it's a sad day in gaming for me so let's
get this thing going like you said on
the screen we got Update 1 evolving
world update to stronger together and
then we got update 3 the Cataclysm now
based on these this is all starting much
that we just we still don't have dates
for these right for these updates yeah
these but it was like they say starting
March 2019 so new events quality life
new rewards expanded progression system
which I'm kind of intrigued on the
pression system new stronghold like
literally in a month
guilds missions Cataclysm cataclysms
like the big question mark so we had a
baby tease of the shaper storm or some
Philly cam cost something like that in
one of the days of the beta so we got to
see when the you know sky goes dark
there's like fireballs falling from the
sky tight and start roaming the earth
and stuff can I go as crazy so
potentially if Cataclysm is like you
know the big giant version of that I
don't know what that means but I'm
curious to find help a new stronghold
coming like literally it's like so take
a stronghold picture a strike in destiny
it's probably similar equation add
another one within a month ish from
launch if they can knock if they could
do that in march depending on timing
that's pretty quick I mean how long did
it take for us to get we got one more
strike probably in December of I'm going
back d1 year one we got crota what do we
get one strike with that probably added
maybe a PlayStation exclusive to maybe
something like that so I mean I looked
up before you had four strikes for
everybody you may have had five as an
exclusive for PlayStation so if you go
for everyone yet four so we have three a
month later we might have four that's
actually not that far apart Cataclysm is
not gonna be a raid great I'll probably
bet money on there we've gonna be a yeah
that's not gonna be a raid
we've conceded that we could see the dad
I mean and look I'm gonna I'm gonna take
a page out of carboxyls book you know
anthem just might not be going for that
no I'm saying as much as I would like it
to have a rate or whatever whatever you
know as long as whatever they decide to
do remember what I told you last you
know last last word which was if they
focus on narrative right if it's really
cool and it advances the story and we
get some cool you know learning about
what's going on and stuff like that you
know at the end of the day you know I'm
cool I'm cool with it doing what it does
and only it does if they continue to do
unique things you be you do narrative do
verticality do Ironman do x-men storm
you have save do warframe ninja you know
sit in classes of my interceptor yeah
you know just do you and keep bringing
content and you know shout out the
cactus he's got a great video right now
and he's like look this thing is flawed
he's so honest he was like this thing is
flawed it's got a lot of issues he's
like but he said just what you said I
love to play it I have a ton of fun
planet and he tell he like he said some
bills when I saw some of his master work
stuff and him and M TAS got stuff where
as a storm everything goes into staying
in the air and doing double damage and
I'm like when he was talking about the
Builder I gonna front I got excited oh
yeah I got to get into I like that you
know so uh that's what I got but I'll
let you finish out at before we get into
the next next one but yeah so I mean
we've got a future coming they've
already got a plan here literally like
laid out and this is Act one there's two
and three they're coming so it's gonna
depend on the cadence but from what
we've seen so far the speed and the
changes the speed and they needed fixes
basically nipping a looot cheese in the
butt really fast it's good yes just
their response time and everything so
far has a lot of promise if they can
keep with it
sorry what were you saying sorry for
interrupting you know just all I was
saying was agreeing with you that bodes
well for the future what you see yeah
absolutely
and that's kind of the hope is I think
this is kind of one of those like bungee
you know the team behind it you've seen
their aspiration of what they want to do
and probably forsaken was the
culmination of that aspiration it was
amazing
finally got some story with Cade we got
really cool to new worlds we got an
in-game world lots of stuff to do really
enjoy forsaken probably like just so so
good the people behind anthem the
passion that you see and what they want
to do is their mm-hmm I've seen it in
like the responsiveness the speed how
much they're interacting with the people
like there's their honest feedback
saying hey this is great you know
definitely in the pipeline pretty high
on the list whatever it is like their
like their transparency has been awesome
and if they can keep that going if they
can keep building on this foundation
it's really really gonna be awesome and
I'm looking forward to what it brings
because this is a difference I mean war
black jacket my Chet said it wells like
where anthem can try over dusting
especially it's a PDE game you can go
absolutely bonkers because you're not
having to worry about balance as you
said some of those builds are just
insane but that's part of the fun now
building an extra mechanics adding new
enemies and things like that they've
literally said be like yeah we're gonna
be adding new enemies things like that
they have the ability to just like stick
a Lego brick on the side because talking
to my brother and stuff like that the
way the game is built it's so
compartmentalized the systems aren't so
interwove and you can't like rip a
blanket apart it's like a lego set you
just keep stacking stuff on top and just
keep adding to it and I think that's
gonna give it the adaptability if like
hey there's just the ability for them to
say hey we've got new enemies in the
world
hey we opened up a new space hey like if
they can continue that at a you know
decent clip I think it's got a lot of
potential so I've been as but as you
said is it perfect no there's many there
are a lot of flaws of the game but it's
an absolute blast and I can't stop I
can't stop playing it's shattered thrown
this week so I'm gonna have some time
but if not I'm definitely gonna be
playing as much of this outside shadow
zone but they do have big patch notes
so we'll cover the big ones decrease
loading times for older disk drives
especially for hard disks of 7200 rpm
5400 rpm depends on what a hard drive
you have those should be better so
that's some one thing they said on them
they're like we should have adapted for
that we're sorry
should be good day one patch and that's
like a pretty quick fix to handle like a
hardware level change fixed meanie
infinite load screens fixing many
challenges not tracking properly a
number of issues have been fixed that
were causing players to disconnect or
crash weapons gear have numbers person
for modifiers so this is all stuff that
was like it's been there since I've been
playing most of this is but like the old
disk drive loading times is like
probably one of the higher ones but
loading screens themselves have been
shortened so this has been a thing too
mm-hmm
I feel like this isn't the right I feel
like this is what I saw that hold on
hold that thought
but I mean how much I won't ask you
while I'm looking at stuff like how much
have you actually played not much man
it's just like I said schedules just
been so brutal for me who else things I
have going on but what the little that I
did play was just basic mission
structure stuff you know going it to be
us I'm so like remember like I didn't
play as much of the demo so I was like
finally got a chance to really customize
and really get busy with the
customization and I got my god oh my
here looking like Captain Britain from
Excalibur he's got like but my store
looks like a Union Jack like British
feel on and he I just love it like the
blue red it's like opposite USA kind of
a deal and like inverted I should say
USA flag kind of a deal yeah love it
let's say I was just styling man I just
love the customization I was messing
around
I had cashed in on my legion of Dawn
stuff that leads to no impact nice man
and I got a masterwork I mean without
Maxima whatever weapon I was like this
thing is super powered like this auto
rifle that I got and it was just cool
messing around with all the other thing
I like this a combo initiators and the
combo finishers I've got what they call
my primers or I forgot what exactly I
mean resonators yes and just learning
that aspect apparently with dispatch I
heard they made things a little bit more
visible now I'm hoping let me ask you
this question is one big negative they
got out of fix though it's one thing I
cannot stand about anthem is Lotus trees
is why is it when you go down you can't
respawn and you're just at the mercy of
whoever you're playing with please tell
me that the patch is going dress that
please that one's not there yet all
right Ellen oh come on that is
definitely a huge high piece of feedback
I've seen them it's it's a pretty highly
unacceptable like to play a game and you
go dan that's like let's play before I
go down hey that's it like if no one
doesn't pick me up that's it
you can't look at their screen you can't
move you have just a big red badge in
the screening you're stuck and that's
like that's one of those where I'm like
somebody like you didn't have enough
people test and either die or get stuck
in that instance where you're just like
this isn't fun like even if you can't
get up quickly in a stronghold you
should have like I mean it's not a you
know Grand Master 3 like if it's just
normal or hard I should eventually be
able to respawn whatever it's like that
should be a thing he said they talked
about it a bit on their livestream no
that hasn't listened to that yet your
design choice like I said go in there
like who's that is it you know what
we're gonna make the we won't penalize
the guy that dress you gonna stuff we go
sit in the corner yeah go watch the
whiskey oh wait do we like that's crazy
to me
so hopefully that gets suggest that like
that was one of my little kind of issues
or whatever but and then I heard about
the without spoiling there's a big
juncture in the quest as you get farther
AmpliTube yeah ok that requires you know
a grind period that's a big controversy
will give it to that a little bit or
I'll mean that did get patched ok so I
heard that got patched you don't say so
so they changed where basically it's a
tracking of certain things I won't say
too much
and they start the tracking much much
sooner so any random fully pliant free
playing any missions you're doing you're
likely to do most of it naturally by the
time you get to the point you need to so
they changed that at me I actually had
done a decent amount but if you know me
at all it's like I'm just gonna go roam
around on a free play for a little while
not just if you just streamline this
like critical path mission don't pick up
any crafting items don't do anything at
all there are some things you're
probably not gonna like hit and you're
probably gonna have to go do some world
events and go do some free play and it's
opening up free play is basically kind
of what it's doing and if at some points
you're just like hey let's go roam
around on free prey for a while
pick up a few chests do some world
events and go pick up some materials
you'll do most of this naturally if you
just go story story story don't touch
anything else and that's it yeah that
one's probably gonna take you a little
longer still but if you play some
natural stuff and do those things yeah
because I was pretty pretty far along
anyway I had to go for him a couple of
things but even there was important you
needed to pick up a certain number of
chests in the open world but you
couldn't do it as a group 15 but you had
to get 60 if you have four people with
you well now if you're in proximity you
get it so if you're playing with friends
just make sure they're close accounts so
stuffing but I mean that's like a
fundamental way to change a quest change
a quest works change didn't like four
days mm-hmm
so I mean it is good start but also it's
like yeah some of the stuff should have
been done better but if somebody like me
played through it and I was just
exploring picking up stuff naturally if
I just spent some time in a free play
and I was like you know I just want to
roam explore this world that would have
been stuff that I probably would have
been farther along so maybe a less of an
issue but take one of my friends
dolorous I don't know if you've ever
played with him you probably haven't a
while since he hasn't been on destiny
but yeah he will just absolutely
streamline just the absolute critical
path skip every cutscene doesn't give a
damn about most those alright just like
he will skip a lot of stuff I mean he
likes Mass Effect so I really enjoyed
those but generally he just will blow
through everything and he would be the
one who day he had a wall
he said he's like that was a struggle
and I told him it was fix later it was
like that was a wall like four that's
why getting that out
this day dispatch for people going live
today was a good thing so they didn't
experience that so that was one of the
biggest ones is that temple as the tombs
yeah but I mean there are certain things
when you go through missions you beat
stuck by a hind invisible walls
that stuff's been fixed but why was it
there in the first place I don't know I
mean those are the questions like they
are fast to fix but why was it there
that's what the questions that's why
that's why it's always it is fun there
are some frustrating moments because
it's flawed but they are trying to be as
fast as they can on some of the stuff so
is it forgivable no but they I mean I
respect them for their speed of their
response so absolutely just get the
speed of the nee spawn down and then
I'll be happy yeah yeah it's just the
loading screens like in for Tarsus like
if you go into your javelin it's a small
one you come back out it's a little
bigger why I always have to load in at
the bottom of horses and then walk all
the way up the stairs and around I can I
just start at the fort and be like hey I
wanna go why is that the hard one is it
cuz it's a harder place to load and
loading me in a small like area is
easier I don't know but I feel when you
load all of for Tarsus anyway but I
carry boom at 60 frames a second a foot
why do we have the the molasses boots oh
it was like there are look they
literally said they buffed it a little
bit and they really did do it a little
bit like I don't know I don't know why
they're like what you can't move that
fast they're afraid to like break the
immersion and for Tarsus I'm like you
could still go like I swear a hundred
percent faster on their spin I'd be like
fine it ain't that big a social no it's
not that it's not that big there's more
people in okay so here's a point it
isn't that big there's quite a few
people in there but sometimes the tower
is too big at least I got the option to
run to the other side run but I was like
I can go like shortly walk up the stairs
or I can go for like a let me put on my
jogging shoes I can go for a mile jog
down to 801 lest that be disrespectful
to the tower down hey you disrespectful
if you for some reason
if sir is in the hangar
you got to go to 801 for one you can
teleport now but for the longest time if
you had to go from sir was in the tower
and they'll be like all I need to go
talk to Hawthorne that's a long run but
at least you had opportunity with you
didn't get to run I was like there as
the games come there's different choices
and stuff like that so all that stuff
but I mean gear and weapons they got
some damage they fixed a couple
different gun changes they got the
Interceptor getting a boost so ice they
even got like there's these are like
sandbox changes in a week mmm-hmm so
like Dead Eye has increased spare ammo
cloudburst has increased damage these
are all different like abilities and
stuff like that that mostly have been a
soft ice tea a that's that's I love that
see I didn't know it now I'm excited to
jump back in like I didn't realize they
did all of this and this is my week so
that that's pretty impressive
you know like bounce on a sandbox batchi
yeah I'm like have the adaptation and
this is the point where it's like a new
patch a new weapons mm a new like bigger
patch new ability sets are dropping like
here's a way to like here's a new primer
a detonator here's something like you
know there's a point where if they did a
full they can do a skill tree for maybe
different Ultimates they could have and
then I and that is one of the it's a
completely fundamentally different game
mmm yeah Phillies had a big one the
colossus gonna hold it shield out and
res people that's huge I mean those
those are big and that was again that
was patched in here as well yeah they
some of the enemies shields were so so
redonkulous like they were really really
beefy they lower the shields down so
lots of things were changed quickly and
there okay changing them because guess
what they can change them back quickly
to it seems absolutely absolute yeah
some of the icons weren't weren't there
which those were fixes those are minor
but I'm like how do you forget icons as
I'm playing an interceptor I was missing
four of them which was gay before to say
they treat for tosses like a church kids
there's no run into the chest
by the pool no running but no running
around that was great
very good media interceptor V so like
the Colossus can now res with the shield
the Interceptor my combo aura which is
half of what I do is much more powerful
wider has a damage tick so I can
actually see what it's doing like
they're taking feedback saying hey
interceptor you can't see it you know it
doesn't last that long
Colossus no longer is being knocked out
of the sky in some situations now that
brings up a point there are times when I
feel like and that's one thing destiny
does really really well is your feedback
from the game is proper it's not too
much but it's not too little like I
don't know where a shot came from and
I'm almost out of health yeah I agree
problem yes yeah and that's the point
I'm like all of a sudden like I'm always
getting down to this like one health and
I mean shoutout to skill up he like he
had a lot of flaws to save at the game
and it's like and obviously I told you I
was like I can't argue with a ton of
them
I still have fun in it I wouldn't say if
you're on the fence about it I'd say
wait a month and then it's probably
gonna continue to get better mm-hmm but
in turn some of those things where it's
like you don't have the feedback of
where a shot came from the hit
registration sometimes is either too
quick you don't know you don't feel the
bullet all those things and all of a
sudden just my health keeps going away
and it's gone and then I have to try and
run and hide we have no healing
abilities and you have to go pick up
your little health packs but if I'm in a
fight and as an interceptor I have to
keep killing
I have no like occasional just heal pop
and it's one of those things almost
every class probably needs in some way
for those moments maybe not that often
but just think usual like hey let me get
an extra shield pop you can't use it
that often to break it but you need some
way to help survive I agree so but yeah
the shield dropping the light shots out
of nowhere or when I'm fighting a Titan
and he does the little like exploding
ball that spawns on four enemy I
literally have to be as fast as possible
to dodge and jump backwards at the same
time as an interceptor because I can
dodge and just like the blast radius of
the little fire orb methyls
fly even which are hard enough to dodge
ones that spawn near you and a little
redundant movement and I still get set
on fire and burning and have to go hide
again so there's some frustration to the
combat but also there's some amazing
parts of the combat so it's it's not per
it's far from perfect it's for exactly
that looks and I just I just like I said
the cadence I like to get on it you know
I would say so long as they just keep
this up I'm good with that
mmm oh but yeah I mean combo like that's
kind of a thing if you I'll kind of wrap
it up here cuz you guys have read the
patch notes if you want to I don't need
to bore you with all those I've skipped
a lot of them anyway
if you figure if you're like hey I'm
gonna run with even just my brother
you can matchmaking with other two
people he's gonna run flamethrower and
venom spray
he doesn't have been him but he's got
flamethrower and one other thing and
he's gonna be like hey actually I think
he does have him um you're I'm gonna
prime all these people set him up you
hang near me we're gonna melt everybody
down cool like and I can go full
detonators where everything I do is
gonna explode everything cause the
combos to go off and we're just trade in
the whole time and that pairing is so
much fun
yes Tombo t is like that sound effects
they nailed there are certain things
that are like okay the sound effects are
like the hit registration not as cool
but that combo ping sounds good every
time yes and that's like the that's the
satisfaction of like shooting off a head
and destiny but combo a name like
psychological just little Peck like it's
not acknowledge me knows good
you know they absolutely mmm-hmm so
there's if you're on the fence about it
and you're not sure what the future is
gonna be wait it's all I can say me I'm
having a ton of fun because you've got
different abilities and that's the thing
you'll get a new legendary gun with this
ability you're like well I get a change
in my build or I got a legendary you
know ice blast for my storm and it's
like okay now I gotta use this thing but
now I got a pair of something differ and
it's gonna change the way you play
mm-hmm and you just have more variety
and how you play for sure so it's got a
whole lot to it
there's a decent amount of fun in the
story
kind of cool voice acting is really good
for toss tarsus needs some tweaks the
loading screens and going back in the
Forge and like not getting your you know
the luke questions are ups and downs but
overall it's it's a fun start and I'm
very intrigued to see where it goes but
as I said flawed but fun that's pretty
much my short summary early what's going
on in like like you said for people on
the fence wait see what you you know see
them improve the things that you need
improving you know I'm saying and if not
and if you like I said if you want to
give this shot and you want to play
something drastically different out of
the three Luther shooters and the mist
again
yeah it's but it's clear shout out the
dizzy he says Prime Harry he said I'm a
war like a dusty so you gotta be meaning
his storm I agree I think warlocks if
you don't add them you got a touch storm
it's the closest I would say you don't
say as far as look wise they definitely
they're a little different but you know
I definitely like the character and he's
out he loves his uh sniper you know
because of the distance he's all about
his range you he's all about his range
so yes so arms a big favorite I see but
low key range is good too man I mean
everyone's good they all got the unique
style man so like I said if you're on
the fence give it a shot give it a shot
I would definitely if you're on PC
go get Origin access for a month mm-hmm
15 bucks check it out if you want xbox
get EA access yeah take your ten hours
and see how it goes and that's it
PlayStation now and I can't help so but
yeah I mean I think one more piece to
because you said it is there are
different classes they feel completely
different because worm is never like the
storm in the Interceptor about as far
apart as you can get storm is literally
like the eye in the sky drop in ice
bombs on people and I'm up there slash
in a slash and with knives I'm using
things like you know assault rifles and
machine guns and heavy pistols and the
dude up in the sky is using a sniper
rifle and a marksman rifle because
you're not in the mix and you're not
going to be accurate from that far away
and you're not meant to be
you're literally meant to play the game
differently as different styles and I
love that so yeah I'm loving my
intercept I switched over to Ranger just
to mix up using a different class for my
stream so I don't make them
throw up haha I will definitely say like
I can I know me playing the Interceptor
and I can watch and I know what I'm
literally anticipating doing in my head
so I know when I turned the screen and I
move and I dodge when I jump over this
thing and I do this and jump back over
I'm like I know what I'm doing in my
head so it doesn't hurt my head but I
literally can't quite imagine watching
stream they've got to be like oh I'm
getting motion sick over here it's a lot
to watch it so on it's very busy but
yeah there's one more piece guys that we
do need to talk about because I've been
waiting so much time here on implement
and you're sitting over there chomping
at the bit thank you no you're like yeah
that's enough ant that's enough and let
let's talk he's gonna run my shot clock
out delay of game no anthem is out right
now so it's good you know love but you
know what my favorite of the new ones is
- division - yes there we go we up
alright so I talked for a while mmm-hmm
I'm gonna let you take this oh my god
dizzy you are so petty he said the last
words finished now or about a hard time
thank you for the support over there for
those agents that still listening oh
yeah man like they dropped a jumper
trailer they had dropped the in-game
trailer oh did you get a chance to see
it yes I did watch it okay cool so
couple of things I saw in there - yeah
so um you know it was cool they pretty
much kind of talked about black tusk and
um me personally I think that's I just
think it's really dope and only from the
standpoint of once the main campaign
main game is finished a new faction
arrives and that is the black tusk
that's the one that has like the robot
dogs you know I'm saying if you look at
that picture in the bottom left where it
says invaded missions they have some
weapons like that heavy highly tactical
kind of guys very different play style
faction and um I thought that's cool
they take over the map there's invaded
missions where now it kind of makes the
older content fresh so I did like that
and as they will continue
that trailer they so showed raid in a
alai quote raid number one you know
there was two yeah well I don't even
know if there's two I'll be I know they
were multiple right but I didn't know
how many so it I'm just happy to see
that there's an additional rate right so
when I see rate number one that just
denotes to me okay boom we we're doing
raids and division now so it is now we
got a name operation dark hours now they
didn't show much but they did show
what's that was that it but what are
they going to do did you see like they
learn a sudden airport
okay cool maybe I mean look at the pen
do see the picture on screen oh yes but
it's kind of not clear so I did what are
the ideas this is a giant jet liner so
it's okay okay okay I am very curious
about this this is um
there's no territory for the division
they didn't have raised before they
showed a cinematic of all eight players
I was about to ask you how many people
but eight plays walking in together into
this move zone so you know I'm I'm so
height just to see I'm just hate to see
I'm not saying alright that's ridicul
know you're not getting that out mama no
you know that I don't know what this is
but I'm excited that they're doing it
they're attempting it and I got some
cool ideas in my head hopefully I don't
have my expectations too high
you're not saying but maybe they split
the guys up you know kind of dig stuff
you know me so I'm I'm just hiding for
that so we see that you know we've seen
the specializations they showed that in
the trailer so basically endgame
leveling you know once you get past the
cap almost any evolution of your
character you get to pick you know these
different styles I forget the names of
top do you remember off top DM was a
demolition a sharpshooter like
demolition I forget the three ones got
the explosive crossbow once got the
grenade launcher ones got a sniper you
ever say so it's like all shout the end
boy he said so looking forward to this
game it's funny how things have changed
Devon pubs know with this type of game
you have to advertise the end I you know
it's funny you say that emboss because
to me
strategic I'm gonna get a little deeper
they've no anthems here right they're
paying attention you know saying they've
been paying attention to destiny they
have been paying attention to what you
know they've had a year to cook and
learn from the mistakes and get better
and I just felt it was so strong of them
but just for my mom whether you like the
game or not you got to give credit to
the marketing team right the marketing
said you know what the anthems getting
killed right now because of Amiens if
you look at the top streamers a lot of
them say hey dang game's boring or
repetitive or whatever there their
cracks are and to come out with a
trailer with all of this endgame content
listing it kudos to the marketing to you
their petty I love them already shout
out to the marketing team for being
petty and see and sensing weakness
because they were like show them the
footage release the info blast I thought
it was cool man you know you got you
know living world activities man inside
mission faction strongholds base of
operation projects settlement projects
clan project clan that's good clan
projects I'm dying to know how clans
work priority target network occupied
dark so long conflict modes we know a
new stronghold high end gear weapon five
world tiers I want to know what's more
about that in depth they've got a lot of
stuff going on man and I'll give it to
you in fact I'm done rambling which is
um this is really creative dizzy I don't
care what you say and um at the end of
the day man like it is just a lot to do
you know saying and they're coming
they're coming again this not might not
be for everybody I get it some people
the minute you you hear tactical and you
hear boots on the ground they don't want
to have nothing to do but I know there
is a lot of people that do love that
aspect and then the division has a
ravenous loyal fan base and to see them
bounce back in this fashion which so far
would it's so far good strong foundation
and we got the March coming up we shall
see so I thought this was cool you know
and um I'll give it to you I
you are not on the division train like
that but uh I was curious to see I guess
about my question you ease on with the
trailer did anything change or was it
like yeah still that old division crap
be honest but would you feel it when you
started shame so I saw a oh I probably
basically called it actually the one of
the larger boss type enemies so big ass
four blade helicopter called a
helicopter mom you gotta slay go back
there bullet sponge we got a big big
bigger bigger vehicles like how big can
they get you're gonna have like Avengers
like Helicarrier eventually but no I
mean like honestly a lot of things
they're doing give the in give the the
world a new coat of paint in a way that
will take something you've probably
grinded before and at least make it feel
somewhat different even if it is more of
you know it's still a tactical shooter
you're gonna take a new faction you're
gonna give them some different AI
different enemies to fight more like
aggressive AI and all those things in
all your mission like you know take
destiny take anthem whatever you gonna
do if you're gonna go back and play
missions how are you gonna play them are
you gonna play them with new enemies in
this one yeah you get to play new
different enemies now how different do
they feel well from the guys on the
street versus the tactical guys will
robot dogs that's probably fairly
different I don't even know what the
strongholds are so see what that is of
the faction we haven't seen all we've
seen is the hyenas in the demo and
apparently there are two other factions
and black tusk yeah yeah black is the
infection right apparently
all three have behavioral differences
and this is again the hate to interrupt
just want to make one good point for the
division haters
in the chat oh the thing that I like is
what makes destiny cool is cabal fallen
vex enemy types and behaviors are they
that extensive in aliens no but what's
cool is with division at least you're
not I feel they have this advantage over
anthem I don't I feel the scars are kind
of generic to be honest you don't say
like I don't I'm not a fan of anthems
enemy outside of the big troll duels
those are though
that's the the bigger enemy is whether
it's the tanks you get the big [ __ ] the
bigger enemies have cool variety the
smaller ones feel throw away a girly
yeah they feel like okay whether it's
the big like truly guys or you get I
will say one one small guy will mess you
up they'll go any element to this type
person the floaty like the enemy storm
type yes yes you up I don't care what
class trouble the loser but it and then
like the machine-gun guys just a little
they're like they're like role I mean
they are like the throw away like little
melee guys or little pea shooters like
they're not gonna be doing too much and
those for sure but as like as you get to
the bigger ones and that's kind of the
thing you get to hear like you'll have
so like on the screen for the invaded
missions you'll see you have your more
tackle guy with is like you know assault
rifle you'll have your big mini gunner
it looks like you have your robot dog
but you don't have like some giant
Colossus suit man walking around and
there's just a difference in what you
can do in realism in tactical versus
sci-fi and that's that's where it's a
preference thing more than anything
whether you like it or not that's
literally just your preference
absolutely again all I'm talking about
is faction and behavioral differences
and that's right cool I like that that's
all I'm saying so yeah I just thought
this was a cool little marketing thing
you know Lizzie but um but the
specialization is cool for any game and
I'm very I'm very curious you know
because I heard it's very extensive from
all accounts that I've heard as far as
customization and how you want to keep
building in your your character post
endgame
I'm dying to touch all that stuff out
man so I'm ready man we got what was it
a March first I believe we have um the
public beta March 1st through 4th like
that it's that yeah I think it's the
Friday through probably like marks for
that like three I'm or whatever it's
probably right through it yeah but yeah
it's that open beta through the weekend
it's probably the same thing we got in
the private beta I imagine they're not
just gonna do a new beta they may have
some patches in there and tweaks and
stuff like that did you do you play the
private didn't you did you play the end
game mission I started the was it the
black dress I didn't get a chance to
finish it actually had to run out put on
I liked what I saw you know sound
definitely the the behavior was
different and I like that you know
saying when I saw robot dogs I got
excited to be honest I didn't think
division would ever go anything past
human human human kind of stuff so I'm
like alright we're thinking outside the
box you know say and they were very
aggressive it was a different a eye
situation going on they were trying to
get me up out of cover they were doing
different things so I'm like okay this
is what I'm talking about
you know I'm saying so we'll see you
know again a lot of things to do you
know we shall see how that rate is and
i'ma tell you right now though if they
knock that raid out the park oh boy
that'll be interesting because they have
a huge leg egg on their face from the
first incursion came out and not fun
like so if they do this right if they
have and that's again how yeah Boston
Dynamics thank you dizzy for those
little robot sex exactly what they look
like not eating much copied and pasted
it just painted black yes nice but more
variety than other enemy types in other
games good I get the out of the way the
blood hate is good with dizzy he's just
going extra extra he's just going our
course you'll be Sophos like Ubisoft
lily has all the best games right now
like literally like every genre they've
improved so you can say what you want
but oh that's right you like Arkadiy my
back continue we know how that is in the
wild-card guys I gotta give flack even
trolling for too many weeks I got I got
a fire off one this week
we know we don't we don't respect the
ark users in here anyway but yeah it's
like you take like an airport setting do
you work through the terminals first you
have like a big food court fight out you
get to like the on the actual tarmac
where you're like working around planes
is there I mean how you know you're on
an airport
so are there military or the big
helicopters like what you find that's
gonna be the big questions like what are
you fighting what mechanics are in there
I mean you take destiny right teams I
mean they're going world or craft levels
some points they're maybe not quite but
they definitely have some amazing
mechanics and changes and variety so
that will be the biggest question as if
to see if that's worth the grind for cuz
you know five different world tiers
that's just difficulty levels similarly
you know your high-end gear and weapons
I don't even remember I don't and that's
one thing we've said even about destiny
I don't remember and named a weapon from
Division one I didn't play it as much so
I fell off so I'm sure there were some
oh no I know they did I'm just saying I
don't remember a name of one and you can
start off Gallimore and last word thorn
all that stuff cuz there was like an
attachment so they you have sets they
have bonuses which is something I wish a
lot of things had because those getting
the combination of like sets of armor
does benefits which I like those pieces
and it's just gonna be does the feel of
it honestly feel good and that's one
thing I'm just gonna have to spend some
time in because the demo is not gonna do
it for me I'm sure I'm gonna get it I
know I'm gonna play it the story do not
seem induced what no I'm surprised you
even gonna get it because I you don't
really seem and dude like I played the
first one in I had a lot of fun leveling
up 1 through 30 and then I hit the and
then the previous one was like I hit the
darkest on wall and it sucked it really
really burned me hard because like me as
a solo player even left like
to people we'd be running around working
stuff going down in the subway system in
New York and found these heavy guys and
working with our cover and using our
abilities like there are some things
about it there were really really fun
for me whatever when I was saying just
like I don't know if it was the mobility
I'm just used to other games some it
felt different Indy - yeah our division
- so me I've just got to see if I just
get past that um and I think it has a
lot of potential because you have the
level up you have the black chest take
over you have the invaded missions again
it's the point of when we went through
[Music]
like the previous part experience the
missions for the first time was cool it
was like how did the spongy how does it
feel how does the spongy news feel how
did the ads feel and how does it go cuz
that's for all of these things like when
I go through and I'm plating like
multiple ads but I'm like do I sit
behind this wall for six hours
you guys come at me Kohi punch it here
punch it here it's like I just want to
see how it feels once I'm actually in
the swing of it so I think it's just
gonna take the whole thing for me you in
yeah I know you you had that it's cool
it's good like I just I'm sceptical in
my attachment level because of game is
the same way you're not in so I was like
we we got both sides I will play it
because I want to be able to talk about
it but I was like my excitement for it
at this point when I stepped in it's
still division and anthem is new so
there's like the shiny coat of paint on
anthem and maybe that will wear off if
act 1 like in fact one is like three
months and it's like the Cataclysm is
coming in June we're like oh man that's
that's gonna be a while it may feel a
huge hole to be like hey I got this I
got raids I got more and then I may get
hyped but I was like right now I just
gotta get I want my hands on the full
game before I get my expectations too
high so I'm reserving myself for a
change on this one - to counter you if
nothing else no my thing is I'm super
excited and like I said the end of the
day nothing nothing's gonna stop by
excited for this they've literally
answered every problem I have had with
division 1 I was not a division 1 fan
that's what's so funny about this whole
thing I'm kind of like become the
champion for division out of nowhere
which is weird because I hate it
Division 1 like I did not after I was
the same thing I beat thee the first
part of it you know campaign did not
like the whatever incursion or whatever
it was called
you know dropped it like a bad habit and
then um I remember it was sinister told
me about a couple updates okay and then
they trot we got me to play survival and
when I play survival then I go okay I
like this this is what it should have
been like this okay cool you know I'm
saying then I played another incursion
Anthony was way better and I'm like okay
and then everything seemed to improve
and I'm just like yo towards the end
like this game it's really good now so
you know that that tomini coming in with
the momentum you know I'm very excited
about that but I'm just honestly I get
tired of doing the same exact thing and
like I said if back to your point with
the shiny can of paint
you know if anthem does it do what they
do which is as far as great narrative
campaign and it's just like okay we're
gonna add a stronghold here I'm gonna
fade out I know me I'm gonna fade out
because at some point there's only so
much PvE you won't do yes it's so boy
yeah I mean and that is true then that's
that's the big test like I know myself
this is it's like playing dead let's
just put it to destiny if all there was
were strikes no gambit no PvP no you
have there just strikes and nightfall
and that's it
strikes a night for strike and we're
adding one more new strike okay cool I'm
gonna drop it like it is nothing else to
do there's no way there's no PB again so
I get the whole Ironman thing I get it I
get it I get it but for those who
continue to slander division diversity a
variety is despite the spice of life
that's what keeps it I know it I've seen
games die red I've seen it I'm not
saying enemies but I'm just saying I
don't have a strong assumption of who
gonna win the endgame if if Bioware
don't do other things that's all I'm
saying
so we can rip not young I'm going after
people that bomb don't like no no you're
you're just we can rip it you know
saying but we'll see
well we'll revisit this six months in I
have no problem telling those that were
hating I told you so I will be back I'll
take my slander dated to yo whatever
bump cog was on you know cogs last name
for division was II was listen trust I'm
good at this because I've had this
conversation with um people who hated on
destiny people who hated on every game
that comes oh this is the Destiny killer
once they don't destiny killer when it's
over in it so they've yet bungees been
yet to be the drone on that and I'm
curious to see what happens with these
uh you two shooters but enough rambling
this is a fun time three great games all
free different you know preference if
you want to you know get your space
magical and you know what to do with a
good gunplay good in-game you know say
it if you want to get that new hotness
flying around you and I mean doing that
great
Iron Man stuff great abilities great
synergy you know I mean boom you don't
anthem is that game and the narrative
that you like characters that you may
like more if you want your tactical you
want your military you want your gear
sets you want your mid maxing you want a
lot of different activities to do your
I'm saying if you you like immersing
yourself in the world when you take back
the world so to speak then yeah
divisions for you you know the cool
thing is listen man shot the Philly
Eagle only buns you could kill best the
yeah I would this is fun I like the
beginning is everybody's competitive I
mean like yeah it's it's interesting to
see to come out so close that and that
will be compared but in the grand scheme
somewhat comparable somewhat not one is
a very PvE one is very much like to a
point of almost both but as you said you
got variety in division which will
potentially give it
then anthem may not have if they don't
have a long pipeline full of content
that'll be that'll be the big one and
it's like but it's like for me Division
two not having survival that maybe a
free update later but that's one of the
ones I was looking forward to and it's
not there
I wanted survival because that was like
I played it a few times and that was fun
I was really good yeah so they've got
more I'm sure they'll bring back some of
that stuff like the underground and
survival and those pieces later but for
now if you're a gamer good luck finding
time to sleep
oh that's about it so yeah seize the
drifter next week watch Bungie watch
their Twitter vitals may be coming tois
will be hopefully full if it's a light
swab we in trouble but yeah if you're
playing anthem enjoy it have fun even if
it's flood I mix it up throw some
lightning down be a ninja divisions
coming you're gonna hold down that cover
and you're gonna pop some heads so
either way my voice is pretty much out
got a serve video yes indeed about 23
minutes so have yourselves an awesome
one guys I am out it's abundance
everywhere YouTube twitch Twitter ebon
just follow like all the good subscribes
producer you already know on Twitter and
the iron law podcast on YouTube please
whatever you do episode 100 episode 50
of last word and now it's ever sowed 100
of the iron law podcast we have got some
special special things to announce
please tune in with if you can if you
have the time Sunday 1 p.m. Eastern
Standard Time
on my podcast YouTube channel it should
be a fun show we will have mr. boomstick
XL no extra guests as well we won't say
who he is
hey he knows who he is don't ya man it's
gonna be a fun show we're gonna really
talk about topics um there there might
be some anthem slander and that's not
for me
and I'm just warning y'all now King
might have a topic I'm just giving you a
little preview you know say about
Metacritic scores and whatever I'm just
warning you it's not coming from me but
I will have some good time let's talk
about everything that's going on in the
industry you know Reggie Phil Phil's
amazing retirement
couple other things but we will have a
monster big announcement and I'm really
excited to share this with you guys and
uh you bought his chairman you guys have
been doing great and it's showing me
support I really appreciate that as well
and IOP faithful you already know what
it is but um and that's all I got um
everybody please enjoy many some great
games Anthony launches today please man
check it out if you know if you're on
offense pick up that EA access pick up
that orange put me a touch to game judge
for yourself
do not get too worked up about reviews
because at the end of the day what's fun
to you is important and that's all I got
well that's all I got - so on that one
have yourselves an awesome weekend try
and sleep somewhere and just have some
fun whatever you like playing I think
that's where we'll leave it eggs
whatever you find fun play it don't let
anybody tell you different scratch
reviews a friend if you're having fun
player games there you go man
everybody enjoy we're out